sehr geehrte frau präsidentin der
bundeskanzler sie haben heute wieder den
begriff der zeitenwende bedient es
gehört inzwischen
zuständigen regelmäßigkeit ihre reden
aber es gibt jetzt einen entscheidenden
unterschied bei ihrer zeitenwende rede
vom 27 februar da hatten sie die
unterstützung weil sie zu notwendigen
entscheidungen bereit waren diese
unterstützung haben sie in dem moment
verloren als sie aufgehört haben diese
zeitenwende zu gestalten das ist der
entscheidung das spiel
der bundeswirtschaftsminister habeck sie
haben uns im sommer mitgeteilt dass sie
die energiedebatte entlang der fakten
führen wörtliches zitat
fakt ist wir haben ein gas problem kein
strom problem mit fakten hat dieser
spruch schon mal rein gar nichts zu tun
habe
sie haben am montag die vorstellung des
stresstests mit den
übertragungsnetzbetreibern
gemacht die haben dabei sehr deutlich
darauf hingewiesen dass die
energiesituation in deutschland massiv
angespannt ist die fachleute haben
erklärt dass eine geordnete
abschaltung von verbrauchern ein
mögliches szenario
geordnete abschaltung von verbrauchern
das heißt übersetzt nichts anderes als
regionaler blackouts sind denkbar die
netzsicherheit sei nur durch strom aus
dem ausland zu gewähren ob es aber zu
diesem zeitpunkt zur verfügung steht ist
vollkommen unsicher und die fachleute
haben ihnen ins stammbuch geschrieben
dass die drei kernkraftwerke einen
beitrag leisten um die last unterdeckung
zu vermeiden er habe was ist da
eigentlich so schwer daran zu verstehen
wer bei dieser analyse
netz sicherheit gefährdet regionale
blackouts denkbar zu der entscheidung
kommt die drei kernkraftwerke nicht
weiter betreiben zu lassen der handelt
nicht entlang der fakten sondern der
handel schlicht verantwortungslos das
ist die wahrheit habe
interessant in diesem zusammenhang
übrigens auch das dann am montag kurz
bevor sie ihre pressekonferenz gemacht
haben den stresstest präsentiert haben
auch der bundesfinanzminister christian
lindner öffentlich mitgeteilt hat dass
die drei kernkraftwerke weiterlaufen
sollen zitat in diesen zeiten sollten
alle möglichkeiten genutzt werden den
strompreis für die menschen und die
betriebe zu reduzieren was ist da
eigentlich so schwer dran zu verstehen
wir brauchen mehr kapazitäten im
strommarkt um die preise zu reduzieren
sie nehmen aber in einer zeit der
größten energieknappheit
kapazitäten aus dem netz sie schicken
sie in die reserve und das in einer zeit
wo die menschen schon am ende mit ihren
reserven sind und die preise nicht mehr
bezahlen können
der bundesminister haarweg sie
ignorieren die ergebnisse dieses
stresstests sie riskieren blick auf sie
setzen bürger und betriebe in diesem
land einem echten massiven stresstest
aus und das alles das alles damit ihre
grünen wahlkampf kollegen in
niedersachsen ihr schönes plakat bei der
atomkraft nicht abhängen müssen das ist
die wahrheit hinter ihrer entscheidung
und särge der bundeskanzler
den grünen energieminister in
deutschland die grüne parteitags basis
wichtiger ist als die
versorgungssicherheit unseres landes
dann sollten sie als bundeskanzler
diesen wirtschaftsminister den stecker
ziehen das ist ihre aufgabe eingestimmt
er wurde es ganz was sie haben heute ja
auch über die lng terminals gesprochen
wir hoffen übrigens dass sie damit
erfolgreich sein werden aber dann
erklären sie uns doch bitte mal an
dieser stelle wie kommt es eigentlich
zustande dass die vereinbarungen die ihr
wirtschaftsminister mit dem land katar
getroffen hat über steuerungsgruppe über
arbeitsgruppen die die
energiezusammenarbeit und die lieferung
von energie aus katar organisieren
sollen schriftlich vereinbart dass diese
arbeitsgruppen nach auskunft des
bundeswirtschaftsministeriums
bis heute kein einziges mal getagt haben
können sie erklären was das mit einer
vorsorglichen
energieversorgung in deutschland zu tun
habe sie reden über allen vier
bundesminister habe hat aus katar keinen
einzigen kubikmeter gas mitgebracht aber
hat den menschen haufen sand in die
augen gestreut das ist doch das was
dahinter steht
sie haben sehr leidenschaftlich hier an
dieser stelle herr bundeskanzler auch
über die gasspeicher in deutschland
gesprochen sie haben darüber gesprochen
dass sie nicht gefüllte worden wären ja
der größte gasspeicher reden ist
deswegen nicht gefüllt worden weil er an
russland verkauft worden ist aber
verhandeln man nur zur aufklärung fasste
sich nicht daran erinnern ja dieser
verkauf war falsch aber derjenige der
den verkauf zugelassen hat das war der
bundeswirtschaftsminister der siegener
gabriel von der spd und niemand anderes
es scheinen ja so warnt irrtümer hier
auch weiter zu gehen der bundeskanzler
hat den brief angesprochen dass er sich
für flüssiggas termin ist besonders
eingesetzt hätte auch gerade gegen den
über den vereinigten staaten von amerika
und sich darüber beschwert dass dieser
brief dann an die öffentlichkeit durch
gesprochen wurde nummer zum hin war es
erstens die deutsche umwelthilfe hat
diesen brief veröffentlicht und zweitens
den diesen brief haben sie ihr
bundeskanzler angeboten eine milliarde
zusätzlich für den bau von terminals
auszugeben wenn die vereinigten staaten
von amerika auf sanktionen gegen
140 herr bundeskanzler die frage ist
doch nicht der hat ihn durchgestochen
die frage ist ob sie verbinden die
arterner darüber gesprochen haben sich
klar und hell
sie rühmen sich hier ja von seiten der
ampel gegenseitig und für ihr neues
entlastungspaket 300 euro für rentner
dass die erkenntnis reichlich spät kamen
geschenkt wir unterstützen diese
anliegen wohngeld kinderzuschlag hat
hier durchaus sinnvolle maßnahmen aber
was ist eigentlich mit denjenigen
menschen die sich nicht auf
transferzahlungen diesem land stützen
können die mittleren die kleinen
einkommen die verweisen sie herr dürr
wir gerade gehört auf die kalte
progression die verweisen sie darauf
dass sie daher großzügig jetzt im
nächsten jahr entlastungen vorsehe ich
gebe ihnen mal ein zitat von
bundesfinanzminister aus dem august wir
sollten diese demokratisch nicht
legitimierten einnahmen zurückgeben das
ist kein gönnerhafte akt sondern in
mehrfacher hinsicht geboten und diese
rückgabe dieser nicht legitimierten
einnahmen wollen sie jetzt den menschen
als große entlastung verkaufen es ist
definitiv keine kluge politik an dieser
stelle
der mittelstand ist ganz besonders von
dieser aktuellen situation betroffen wir
erleben aktuell bereits die ersten
insolvenzen das institut für
wirtschaftsforschung rechnet ihnen vor
dass die insolvenzen im herbst deutlich
ansteigen werden teile des mittelstands
die kleine betriebe die handwerker die
echten unter diesen lasten der
explodierenden energiepreise und sie
wollen nicht ausreichend gegensteuern
die energiepreis explosion wird wenn sie
nicht bekämpft wird nur zu einer
einzigen frage bei den mittelständlern
den handwerkern den kleinen unternehmen
führen abwanderung oder einstellen des
geschäftsbetriebs das ist die
alternative vor denen diese menschen und
unternehmen steht und sehr geehrter herr
bundeswirtschaftsminister sie rechnen
ihr anders als die wirtschaftsinstitute
offensichtlich nicht mit einer
insolvenzwelle zumindest haben sie uns
das gestern abend über die medien
mitgeteilt aber sie können sich
vorstellen dass bestimmte branchen
wörtlich nicht mehr produzieren oder
einfach aufhören zu verkaufen bei den
besten willen und mit verlaub herr
minister es ist den menschen scheißegal
wie sie das nennen wenn sie arbeitslos
aber sie sind nicht egal wenn sie nichts
dagegen unternehmen an dieser stelle
hätten weder die redezeit war um
dr sie haben uns mit unserem programm
auf der zug speziellen vielen stellen
hier zitiert ich frage mal umgekehrt an
der stelle wie halten sie es denn
eigentlich in dieser ampel koalition mit
ihren anliegen sie selber haben
angesprochen sie werden ja dafür dass
die kernkraftwerke weiterlaufen spd und
grüne sind dagegen sie wollen ja die
schuldenbremse einhalten spd und grüne
stellen das tagtäglich in frage sie
behaupten sie wollen entlastungen für
bürger und betriebe offensichtlich war
sie mit spd und grünen nicht zu machen
mittelstand schützen ihr thema fällt
offensichtlich in dieser koalition aus
dem ländlichen raum haben sie
interessiert wollen sie unterstützen
diese regierung macht politik gegen die
ländlichen raum technologieoffenheit was
ist mit dem verbrennungsmotor sie
konnten sich am schluss nicht
durchsetzen dass er mit alternativen
kraftstoffen weiter betrieben mal ganz
ehrlich gesagt hat was machen sie
eigentlich in dieser koalition in dieser
links neben oper zahlung blicks miguel
koalition das ist die wahrheit
alexander dobrindt der landesgruppenchef
der csu griff vor allen dingen robert
habeck an wir haben ein gas problem kein
strom problem dieses zitat von habe hat
er genüsslich immer wieder vorgetragen
er hat dem bundeswirtschaftsminister
vorgeworfen mit der entscheidung über
die atomkraftwerke verantwortungslos zu
handeln sie riskieren blackouts damit
ihre wahlkampf kollegen in niedersachsen
ihr wahlplakaten bei atomkraft weiter
plakatieren können das ist die wahrheit
herr bundeskanzler sie sollten diesen
wirtschaftsminister den stecker ziehen
nichts erinnern jetzt wollten sie nicht
der fraktionsvorsitzende der spd der
wählerinnen und wähler der regierung das
vertrauen ausgesprochen freiheit
gerechtigkeit und nachhaltigkeit
bei uns und in europa zu stärken das war
kein irrtum des souveräns oder ein
betriebsunfall der demokratie wie manche
versuchen uns einzureden
oder bei zu texten die mehrheit der
menschen wollte diese regierung sie
wollte kompetenz erfahrung und
seriösität im bundeskanzleramt sie
wollte olaf scholz und wir
sozialdemokraten die sozialdemokraten
sind stolz dass er einer von uns sitzen
meine meine fraktion meine damen und
herren will dieses vertrauen im
kommenden haushaltsjahr tief verankert
um arbeit zu sichern und den klimawandel
und die pandemie zu bewältigen brauchen
wir ein verantwortliches gemeinwesen und
eine gerechte politik dafür wird sich
die spd bundestagsfraktion in den
nächsten wochen einsetzen und es wird in
der zweiten und dritten lesung ein guter
aus als seien das sagen wir heute zu
meine damen und herren und es geht um
mehr
vor dem hintergrund alter und neu
entfesselter kriege brauchen wir
militärische sicherheit die zugleich in
der täglichen suche nach frieden
eingebettet bleiben muss
diplomatie diplomatie meine damen und
herren und der versuchs spannungen zu
mindern sind keine prinzipien von
gestern sondern aktueller denn je das
hat die bundestagspräsident leute in
ihrer würdigung von präsident
gorbatschow noch einmal nachhaltig
beschrieben wir stehen in dieser
tradition liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
und wenn ich sage eine politik die das
innere und äußere zu verbessern sucht
dann braucht man ernsthaftigkeit und
kompetenz und keine beliebigkeit herr
kollege merz und ich würde gerne an drei
beispiele aus den letzten wochen
erinnern noch im juli haben sie eine
steuerliche erleichterung für alle
gefordert auch für große vermögen und
dann drehte sich plötzlich der wind in
der innenpolitik und dann haben sie
gesagt na ja vielleicht muss das untere
drittel auch bedacht wenn herr kollege
merz ist alles heiße luft sie hätten den
beweis antreten können vor einigen
monaten als es um den mindestlohn
gegangen ist da haben sie sich enthalten
ein tatkräftiges jahr mehr erforderlich
gewesen
und ich kann diesen vor augen führen
meine fraktion war in dresden gewesen
doch profitieren am ersten oktober
35.000 beschäftigte alleine von diesem
mindestlohn und es hätte sich gehört
wenn man meint ein soziales herz zu
haben zuzustimmen und hier nicht nur im
in beliebigkeit sich zu verheddern
sondern letztlich zu sagen ja das machen
wir und das ist die richtige
entscheidung
meine damen und herren
und im märz haben sie einen kompletten
die verstopfung russisches gas hier das
wort geredet und ich frage sie ja märz
wiese in die speicherstände heute aus
wie sähe der herbst und der winter für
die verbraucherinnen und verbraucher aus
es tut mir leid ihre energiepolitische
weitsicht geht gegen null auch heute der
kollege merz
und dann haben sie
im juni
ich kann es nicht verschweigen sich für
ein eingreifen der nato stark gemacht
wenn atomkraftwerke in der ukraine
angegriffen werden und leider wie andere
auch können sie sich offensichtlich
nicht mehr vorstellen dass es wenigstens
noch die chance für diplomatie und
alternativen geben muss als nur das
militärische und die vereinten nationen
haben das bewiesen der generalsekretär
der vereinten nationen oder grossi der
chef der internationalen
atomenergiebehörde ich danke den
mitarbeitern im namen meiner fraktion
der internationalen atomenergiebehörde
die in die ukraine gereist sind und
sozusagen ein schutzschild versuchen
aufzubauen gegen die weiteren angriffe
auf dieses atomkraftwerke und er märz
sie meinen sie müssten hier ein
kronzeugen einen kronzeugen dem man ja
schätzen kann mit einem langen zitat
bedienen
professor herfried münkler hat im jahre
2002 in einer vielzahl seiner
publikationen und bücher und ich zitiere
der klassische zwischenstaatliche krieg
ist ein historisches auslaufmodell
prognostiziert und da finde ich sollte
man sich mal überlegen ob
wissenschaftliche vergesslichkeit und
besserwisserei hier zu einem zitat
dienst lieber kollege merz deswegen sage
ich besonderheit klarheit und kompetenz
dass es derzeit gefragt und keine
sprücheklopfer wright so kann man kein
land regieren und deswegen haben wir als
koalitionsparteien am wochenende ein
drittes ein umfangreiches entlastungs
paket auf den weg gebracht kraftvoll und
gerecht und wie die beiden anderen
koalitions fraktionen auch haben wir uns
in der sommerpause inhaltlich damit
beschäftigt wir haben nicht jeden tag
ein neues thema durch die medien
getrieben zumindest haben wir auch keine
vorschläge zur körperhygiene hier
hinterlassen sondern wir haben ein
kraftvolles papier in dresden
beschlossen was für uns wichtig gewesen
war für diejenigen die für uns
verhandelt haben auch im
koalitionsausschuss durchzusetzen und
deswegen kommt es jetzt in den nächsten
wochen darauf an so schnell wie möglich
diese beschlüsse in die tat umzusetzen
und da wo nachbesserungen gebraucht
werden wird meine fraktion dafür auch
das notwendige tun lieber kolleginnen
und kollegen
und ja in
das bedeutet mehr als nur ein paar
stellschrauben zu drehen
es bedeutet auch ein
systematisches eingreifen in das was
immer wieder behauptet wird und was
sozusagen im geheimen im verborgenen
funktioniert nämlich die geheimen kräfte
des marktes da waren wir schon beim
wohnungsmarkt wir sozialdemokraten
sozialdemokraten anderer meinung gewesen
als wir uns für die mietpreis bremse
eingesetzt haben und genau so ist es
jetzt für den strommarkt es ist richtig
dass wir den europäischen weg gehen aber
gleichzeitig wenn europa nicht die kraft
aufbringt dann werden wir hier wie
andere länder in der europäischen union
ungerechtfertigte gewinne vom strommarkt
abschöpfen und ja wir wollen
vergleichbares auch für die anderen
teile des wärmemarktes auf den weg
bringen wir bieten unsere fachlichkeit
auch für diese arbeitsgruppe an die sich
für die nächsten wochen auch weitere
vorschläge für diesen markt überlegen
wird und meine damen und herren auch bei
diesem entlastungspaket geht es eben
nicht um almosen wie manchmal behauptet
wird sondern für uns sozialdemokraten
sozialdemokraten das war immer tief
verankert in unserer seele in unserer
programmatischen bekenntnis wir wollen
keine almosen wir wollen soziale rechte
die am ende auch den bürgerinnen und
bürger einklagen können und deswegen
schaffen wir ein neues bürgergeld meine
damen und herren und wir schaffen eben
auch die ausweitung für eine
wohngeldreform die es verdient auch
dafür einzutreten und zum schluss bin
ich darauf hinweisen ja es ist doch
nicht falsch menschen dies unmittelbar
brauchen auch konkret zu entlasten und
auch das haben wir im dritten
entlastungs paket auf den weg gebracht
rentnerinnen und rentner studierende
diejenigen schülerinnen und schüler die
bisher davon nicht profitiert haben die
fachschüler und die auszubilden und das
ist wichtig und dass das noch in diesem
jahr kommt dafür stehen wir ein und
dafür ist auch gut vorgesorgt dass in
diesem haushalt das finanziert werden
kann
und ja liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
es ist auch eine vorausschau ein angebot
an andere institutionen und akteure in
diesem land gemacht worden die sich
nicht verstecken dürfen in dieser krise
und auch das ist etwas was die dna der
sozialdemokratie betrifft wir wollen
alle dass sie ihren beitrag leisten und
der staat geht jetzt durch diesen
beschluss auch in vorleistungen und
nicht appelliere an die
tarifvertragsparteien an die unternehmen
geben
sie den arbeitnehmerinnen und
arbeitnehmer sicherheit wir geben die
sicherheit dass 3000 euro im jahr
einmalzahlung abgaben und steuerfrei
sind und das ist ein gutes angebot in
dieser krise meine damen und herren wir
wollen die freiheit der menschen vor
furcht und not das ist unser auftrag und
unser streben zugleich vielen dank
rolf mützenich der fraktionsvorsitzende
der spd in einer an anderen
zurückhaltenden art als die meisten
seiner vorredner er hat gesagt
besonnenheit und kompetenz ist gefragt
und keine sprücheklopferei damit kann
man nicht regieren sagte er in richtung
der cdu und in richtung von friedrich
merz
der nächste redner jetzt hier timo
kubala
spd an hört da kann man wirklich sagen
ein esel nennt den anderen langohr das
ist ihre diskussion und ihre
streitkultur hier
deutschland aktuell verändert sich in
rasender geschwindigkeit ehemals das
wirtschaftliche aushängeschild in europa
sind wir auf dem besten weg vom geber
zum empfänger lang zu werden der
furchtbare umstand ist ukraine krieg
zerreißt europa von deutschland befindet
sich in einer neuen dauerhaften
abhängigkeit zu den usa und über die
wirklichen ursachen ja scholz haben sie
kein einziges wort verloren mittels
eines weitreichenden wirtschaftlichen
sanktions regime gegen russland werden
die uns stück für stück isolieren und
die handlungsmöglichkeiten
einschränken der von robert habeck
angezettelte wirtschaftskrieg auf basis
dieser sanktion schadet deutschland
unseren bürgern aber nicht russland
anstelle der ukraine krieg
schnellstmöglich beenden zu wollen
liefert die bundesregierung weiter
schwere waffen anstelle auf allen
diplomatischen wegen zwischen russland
und der ukraine zu vermitteln zb mit
einer friedenskonferenz hier in berlin
wird medial immer wieder öl ins feuer
gegossen anstelle deeskalierend zu
wirken möchte die bundesregierung ihre
ideologien durchsetzen ergebnis russland
hat die lieferung von erdgas über nord
stream 1 eingestellt bis die sanktionen
aufgehoben sind und da muss man wirklich
fragen macht sie das eigentlich nicht
nachdenklich stehen hier die
eingesetzten mittel und die ergebnisse
noch in einem verhältnis das deutschland
nutzt fragen sich dass russland sei kein
zuverlässiger partner mehr hat
bundeskanzler stolz gesagt herr
bundeskanzler auch partnerschaften
müssen gepflegt werden und
hätten sie alle hier wirklich geglaubt
hätten sie hier alle wirklich geglaubt
dass russland diese sanktionen demütig
entgegennimmt auch stellt sich die frage
unserer zuverlässigkeit haben wir die
langfristigen förderverträge
aufgekündigt welche fördermengen wurden
eigentlich bestellt gas oder öl wurden
die abgenommen was haben wir eigentlich
bezahlt fragen über fragen die die
bundesregierung nicht beantwortet die
bundesregierung treibt in dieser
situation siegesgewiss die energiewende
munter voran am berg gehört ohne
rücksicht darauf die bürger im eigenen
land zu verlieren denn das ziel der
energiewende ist gescheitert
beziehungsweise war nie erreichbar da
erstens ein energieträger durch einen
anderen ersetzt werden sollte zweitens
wir weiter auf fossile energieträger
oder kernenergie angewiesen sind im
übrigen hätten wir hier herr merz in
diesem bundestag eine mehrheit die
kernenergie weiter zu betreiben und
drittens
fragen sie weiter dazu bei dass der
energiebedarf weiter wächst politische
ziele maßnahmen die digitalisierung
elektromobilität um den ausstoß von co2
zu reduzieren oder jetzt die
glorifizierung der luft wärme pumpe
zeigen dass sie sich stets ausweise mit
problemen lösungen beschäftigen und ich
frage sie leider sarah engels weg kennen
sie sich wirklich so schlecht aus oder
ist es sich einfach nur egal wie unsere
bürger ihr leben bestreiten sollen aber
das haben sie ja gestern auch
eindrucksvoll abends bewiesen und da
muss man sich wirklich fragen habe ich
sie haben von wirtschaft wirklich so
viel ahnung wie ein blinder von farbe
und
lassen sie mich mal kurz darstellen
warum bald viele wohnungen und häuser
kalt bleiben was meinen sie wie wird
eine luftwärmepumpe endlich angetrieben
da möchte ich in ein klassisches
beispiel geben damit wir mal die
wirklichen zahlen sehen ein energetisch
saniertes haus ein einfamilienhaus 250
quadratmeter eine fünfköpfige familie
bezahlt im jahr 2021 gas bei einem
verbrauch von 24.000 kw bei einem preis
von 5,4 cent von 1470 euro aktuell
was diese familie bei gleichem verbrauch
und 30 cent die kilowattstunde
7370 euro gas bezahlen + 6
grund gas kreisumlage von 580 euro sind
7950 euro
das ist die fast 47 tagung des
energiepreises und nutzen auch keine 200
oder 300 euro almosen war es nie bereut
und
wenn ich jetzt auf die wärmepumpe gehe
könnte ich jetzt auf die wärmepumpe
geben von haar wäre das allheilmittel
denn würde dieses haus zwischen 8.000
und 10.000 kw verbrauchen weil eine
wärmepumpe nati strom braucht beim
aktuellen kilowattstundenpreis von strom
von 63 cent würde das bedeuten
6400 euro mit der wärmepumpe aber herr
habig müsst ihr natürlich den
energieanbieter immergrün nehmen das ist
ja eigentlich den leuten auch schuldig
dort beträgt der kilowattstundenpreis 1
euro können sie alle nachschauen das
würde bedeuten
10.000 euro stromkosten für dieses haus
und daran zerplatzt ihre grüne ideologie
allein an diesem rechenbeispiel einfach
mal nachrechnen
und wo wir gerade bei den bestehenden
häusern sind oftmals müssten die sie
auch komplett saniert werden damit diese
heizsysteme doch überhaupt funktionieren
aktuell haben wir 32 millionen wohnungen
also knapp 80 prozent die älter als 30
jahre sind die da in frage kommen die
diese umrüsten müssten auch
fußbodenheizung dämon belüftungssysteme
damit überhaupt eine fußbodenheizung
eine dame funktioniert es kann natürlich
auch sein muss man wirklich sagen dass
die bundesregierung auch hier wieder
einen plan in der tasche hat nach 19
grad im wohnzimmer dem waschlappen haben
wir schon gehört einmal duschen pro
woche kommt vielleicht noch die
staatlich verordneten wollsocken dazu
nach der masken pflicht also hier sieht
man diese unglaubliche ideologie der
bundesregierung und das eigentlich
unglaubliche an dieser wahren geschichte
sie wird auch noch staatlich gefördert
werde die bundesregierung sie befinden
sich nicht in einem planspiel politik
was sie hier betreiben wird zur bitteren
realität für alle bürger und unternehmen
und sie verhöhnen alle die tagtäglich
zur wertschöpfung beitragen
[Applaus]
denn ihre vorschläge sie tragen nicht es
kann natürlich auch daran liegen dass
ich kaum jemand in ihren reihen mit
machbarkeit überhaupt noch
auseinandersetzt wasser kommt aus der
leitung strom kommt aus der steckdose
das ist ihre politik setzen sie doch zur
abwechslung smart mich mal mit den
leuten zusammen die von technik an und
haben die diese technik verbauen das
sind die handwerker die können ihre
zauberhaften geschichten aus ihren
kinderbüchern in die lebenswirklichkeit
umsetzen und sollten sie denn in
deutschland noch einen handwerker finden
der in den nächsten jahren noch freie
termine hat wäre das sicherlich gut
sollte sie dann auch noch das
baumaterial verfügen weil die
lieferketten die sie zerstört haben doch
vorhanden sind wäre es noch besser
allerdings sorgen sie mit ihrer
wirtschafts und bildungspolitik seit
jahrzehnten dafür dass es bald keinen
mittelstand mehr geben wird er drückt
unter der enormen abgabenlast gegängelt
durch zertifizierungen der europäischen
union sorgt ihre desaströse energiewende
politik endgültig für den tod vieler
branchen und es hat bereits leider
begonnen sie sehen wir haben es hier mit
dem ausverkauf unserer interessen zu tun
die bundesregierung steht sich selbst
und unserem land im wege und glauben sie
wirklich dass die menschen nicht
erkennen wer sie hier für spielchen
treiben es geht hier um den wohlstand in
unsere eltern an dem unsere großeltern
erarbeitet haben um wohlstand und vor
allem auch um werte die über
generationen in den familien gewachsen
sind grüne ideologen zerstören alles in
windeseile und das verheerende ist dass
die ehemalige mittelstand und handwerk
partei fdp hier auch noch beifall
klatscht sie sind genauso gescheitert
liebe bürger sie bekommen von dieser
bundesregierung keine ehrlichen
alternativen angebot die politik dieser
ampel koalition erklärt immer zuerst was
es nicht mehr geben darf als notwendig
wird sanktioniert um den eigenen willen
durchzusetzen oder sogenannten freunden
zu gefallen die alte regierung verliert
den gesamtzusammenhang vollkommen aus
dem blick sie betreibt flickschusterei
mit dem ergebnis dass wir mehr und mehr
unseres wirtschaftlichen wohlstandes
verlieren die milliardenschweren
rettungspakete mit denen sie hier
erfolge ihrer regierungspolitik
verkaufen wollen haben die menschen da
draußen alle hart erwirtschaften
vergessen sie das bitte nicht und alles
was dem deutschen vielleicht gefällt
oder nicht mehr gefällt das werden sie
jetzt auch auf der straße kundtun dürfen
und das ist ihr grundrecht auf die
straße zu gehen um zu demonstrieren dass
ist das was jedem bürger frei steht
[Applaus]
und deshalb zum abschluss wir brauchen
weiterhin russisches gas um eine
grundlastfähige reform des
energiesektors zu verwirklichen und
darin und darin sind sich der sächsische
ministerpräsident michael kretschmer und
die alternative für deutschland einig
deshalb hat bundeskanzler schaffen sie
tatsachen und machen sie schluss mit den
wirtschaftskrieg in russland wir
brauchen eine interessengeleitete
außenpolitik für deutschland und den
kontinent europa vielen dank
der bundestag ist in der aussprache der
generaldebatte am mittwoch in der
haushaltswoche und der nächste redner
kommt von den bündnis grünen andreas
aurich er stellvertretender
fraktionsvorsitzender
frau präsidentin sehr geehrte damen und
herren
der etat des kanzleramtes ist auch der
kultur etat und gerade nach der rede die
wir hier von herrn koop aller gehört
haben kann es glaube ich nicht
eindrücklicher sein dass wir uns
klarmachen müssen dass wir über die
freiheit von kultur dass wir über
meinungsfreiheit und dass wir auch über
desinformationen reden müssen sie von
der afg sind steigbügelhalter für die
russische propaganda sie machen das auf
den marktplätzen und sie machen das hier
im parlament herr kubaner sie waren 2020
im dezember schon in moskau haben sich
von herrn laubhaufen norden lassen und
genau diese linie die produzieren sie
hier im deutschen bundestag und frau
beide bei ihnen ist es nicht besser sie
haben gerade eines getan hier im
deutschen bundestag sie haben die
propaganda die von russischen namen
account im twitter gestreut wurde gegen
die deutsche außenministerin eins zu
eins wörtlich hier ins hohe haus in den
bundestag getrag das ist nicht nur
schäbig dass es gefährlich und deswegen
ist eines klar wir werden mit aller
kraft die wir aufbringen können dagegen
halten und das unterbinden und das tun
wir das tun wir nicht alleine sondern
das tun wir mit vielen kultur und
medienschaffenden journalistin
journalisten aus russland aus der
ukraine
und deswegen bin ich froh dass wir ein
programm aufgelegt haben in höhe von
sechs millionen euro die das menschen
journalistin journalisten aus der
ukraine aus russland die hierher kommen
unterstützt damit sie weiter machen
können sie dass sie weiter dagegen
arbeiten können dass gerade jetzt in
zeiten in denen die freiheit in frage
steht in denen die meinungsfreiheit in
frage steht und autoritäres gedankengut
um sich greift dass diese stimmen der
freiheit dann nicht verstummen
und wir haben weitere sechs millionen
zusätzlich für die deutsche welle
eingestellt und an dieser stelle greifen
die außenpolitik unserer außenministerin
annalena baerbock und die kulturpolitik
von claudia roth gehen hand in hand und
greifen ineinander die klare kante gegen
putin die heißt auch dass wir eine klare
kante gegen des informationen und
gegenpropaganda haben und deswegen ist
richtig dass diese sechs millionen euro
in die ausweitung des angebotes auf
ukrainisch und auf russisch gehen wir
werden nicht zulassen dass
desinformation raum greift wir gehen
international und in deutschland gegen
wladimir putin und gegen auf propaganda
von ihnen mit aller härte vor
es gibt
eine zweite ebene der auseinandersetzung
putins gas krieg gegen deutschland und
europa wird gerade für viele
kulturschaffenden besonders hart werden
das sind menschen die bereits sich durch
zwei corona winter gequält haben die
noch nicht wissen wie der nächste winter
wird wie corona sich weiterentwickelt
und die jetzt beobachten müssen das
wegen der steigenden preise die
angesichts der fossilen inflation die
von putin gezielt auf den weg gebracht
wurde ihre
produktionen ihre theater schwer zu
finanzieren sind ausgerechnet der
bereich der in unserer gesellschaft
kritisch ist die leute die da sind wenn
es darum geht dass informationen auch zu
decken diese menschen in den theatern in
den bibliotheken in den
produktionsfirmen die stehen jetzt unter
druck mich haben in den vergangenen
wochen sehr viele hilferufe erreicht aus
dieser szene und ich kann ihnen sagen
wir sehen diese probleme wir nehmen die
auf und deswegen haben wir auch am
letzten wochenende genau diese frage bei
den verhandlungen im kanzleramt
adressiert im sonderform des bundes für
kulturveranstaltungen sind restmittel
vorhanden und der deutsche kulturrat hat
berechnet dass dort etwa eine milliarde
euro noch zur verfügung steht ich freue
mich sehr dass dieses geld nun nicht an
den finanzminister zurück fließt sondern
dass es investiert wird dass es da
investiert wird wo es jetzt gebraucht
wird bei den kulturschaffenden die in
dieser zeit eine so wichtige rolle für
die meinungsfreiheit für den diskurs in
unserem land spielen und ich freue mich
sehr dass der deutsche kulturrat
angekündigt hat dass er vorschläge
machen will dass er mit offensiv in die
debatte gehen will wie wir das jetzt
schaffen über den winter lassen sie uns
kräfte bündeln lassen sie uns gemeinsam
gute ideen zusammen nehmen lassen sie
uns das geld nehmen und das bestmögliche
tun dass über den winter alle die im
kulturbetrieb unterwegs sind alle die an
der stelle dafür sorgen dass wir
klarheit haben in der debatte dass wir
wissen und das wie kritisch sind wenn
die propaganda wieder kommt ob von
russland über oder mittelbar von ihnen
von der afg dass wir diese menschen
schützen und dass wir diesen menschen
unterstützen die dort stehen und die
diese arbeit für uns machen es werden
schwierige verhandlungen werden wie
immer es an der stelle nicht genug geld
da wie wir insgesamt die frage haben wie
wir im winter die notwendigen fragen
investieren aber ich kann ihnen eine
sache sagen die eine milliarde die steht
jetzt zur verfügung wir gehen mit den
kulturinstitutionen ins gespräch wir
werden lösungen finden das alle die die
in der kulturbranche unterwegs sind
unsere unterstützung dabei haben gut
durch diesen winter zu kommen herzlichen
dank
der kollege otto fricke ist auf dem weg
zu uns zu sprechen für die fdp-fraktion
frau präsidentin männlichen kollegen
klingen zur kultur komme ich gleich
nochmal kollegen darauf hinweisen noch
steht die milliarde nicht zur verfügung
noch muss dieses parlament beraten noch
müssen wir das im haushaltsausschuss
klären und dann müssen wir aber sehr
sehr genau gucken und das ist gerade bei
der kultur milliarde so wichtig wie wir
zielgenau an der stelle helfen denn das
wird für den einzelnen kultur schafft
eine ganz große aufgabe sein und ich
sage das auch für alle die jetzt hier
zuhören und zuschauen ja es gibt im
kulturbereich bedenken ob das im winter
wieder geht ob man zu einem
veranstaltung gehen kann oder nicht aber
bitte überlegen sie an der stelle auch
dass jedes mal wenn ich es mir bequem
machen und sagen ich verzichte auf
kultur dann zerstöre ich auch ein teil
von kultur weil nicht die möglichkeit
besteht dass ein kulturschaffender eine
kulturschaffende ihre kreativität auch
an den menschen an die bürgerinnen an
den mitbürger bringen kann das wird eine
wichtige aufgabe in der kulturpolitik im
herbst im winter dann auch sein meine
damen und herren zum haushalt die
schuldenbremse wird eingehalten das war
etwas wo viele gesagt haben das geht
nicht das ist aber nicht nur ein zeichen
von einem angeblichen fetisch oder
irgendetwas das sage ich auch in
richtung linke das ist freilich eine
verfassung das ist eine verfassung die
wir einheiten und eine verfassung als
fetisch zu bezeichnen finde ich schon
sehr sehr bemerkenswert war das zeigt
ihr verständnis vom grundgesetz doch
sehr sehr deutlich meine damen und
herren das zweite ist wir halten das
auch deswegen ein weil wir ein zeichen
nach europa und in die welt geben dass
dieser staat versucht auch über die
rettungspakete zu helfen wo er kann wo
er muss aber gleichzeitig immer im auge
hat das ja das dauerhaft tun will seine
leistungsfähigkeit erhalten will an
spätere generationen denken dieses
zeichen müssen wir auch geben denn woran
liegt denn die unruhe die wir alle
verspüren nicht nur bei uns sondern auch
in unserem freundeskreis bei bekannten
bei familie bei menschen die in der
arbeit sind sie liegt auch daran dass
wir nicht klar wissen wie diese zukunft
genau funktionieren das weiß hier
übrigens keiner genau und deswegen
versuchen wir mit diesem haushalt und
mit diesen rettungspaketen dafür zu
sorgen dass wir reagieren können und ich
glaube ist ein sehr gutes drittes
entlastungspaket mit dem wir in den
herbst in die verhandlungen dann bis zum
10 november auch in ein haushaltsgesetz
2023 geben können herzlichen dank dafür
an die verhandler
übrigens kleine anmerkung ich freue mich
auch sehr dass die koalitionsparteien in
dem papier auch noch mal deutlich rein
geschrieben haben dass die
schuldenbremse auch in den
haushaltsberatungen gilt und auch das
ist ein teil dessen was wir uns für die
nächsten wochen und monate klar vor
augen halten dürfen dennoch komme ich
auch heute wieder zu der leeren bank es
war heute ein ministerpräsident da ich
glaube das lag weniger an der debatte
hier sondern mehr da man das ist ein
sommerfest in nrw gibt aber stellen wir
das dann mal hin dann war der da als der
oppositionsführer geredet hat dann waren
da als der bundeskanzler gerät hat und
als die afb geredet hat und als der
koalitionspartner liebe grüne aus nrw
gerede dann ist dann gegangen würde ich
mir auch mal überlegen was das dann
eigentlich an der stelle zeigt ist zeigt
aber etwas anderes die länder haben
immer noch nicht verstanden was in einem
föderalen staat in dem sie mehr
steuereinnahmen haben als der bund vom
momentan mehr steuereinnahmen als bunt
was ihre aufgabe ist und wenn sie dann
sagen ja die haben ja so viel
belastungen zwischen man nicht sagen
dass man 2021 der bund hat ein
finanzierungssaldo von minus 103 essig
milliarden dieses jahr geplant 117 die
länder hatten im letzten jahr ein
finanzierungssaldo von wissen sie es -
nein es war plus die länder hatten einem
plus im letzten jahr wir machen
verschuldung um zu helfen und die länder
sagen da haben wir ganz wenig mit zu tun
und wenn der bund ein angebot macht für
ein gutes ende geht und wir wollen und
wir müssen besseren öpnv rau haben dann
sagen die länder ist ja nettes angebot
aber wir reden doch nochmal darüber dass
hier noch mehr zeit für dinge wo wir
zuständig sind und dann immer dieses
jahr aber die wende haben so viele
verwaltungsaufgaben und das dann sage
ich ihm ehrlich wenn sie sagen dass sie
die länder gegen den bund aufnehmen
wollen beim land das stimmt sind viele
verwaltungsausgaben viele
personalausgaben aber die sozialausgaben
das sollten sie als linke viel viel
besser wissen die liegen beim bund und
wenn ich abwägen muss als liberaler mit
meiner fraktion und mit dieser koalition
zwischen verwaltungsausgaben und
sozialausgaben dann weiß ich auf welcher
seite diese koalition steht meine damen
und herren deswegen sage ich auch in
anlehnung an den alten grundsatz
knowtech station des aussetzers
enttäuschen man kann das aus sicht der
länder auch mal anders sagen nur der
kann mit entscheiden der auch mit zahlt
entsprechend seiner
verfassungsrechtlichen verantwortung und
da setze ich auf den bundeskanzler der
ja mal ministerpräsident weiß und weiß
welche klebrigen fingern da kommen denn
das wird für die verhandlungen glaube
ich bei uns noch sehr sehr schwierig
werden wie die auswirkungen dessen was
die ministerpräsidenten wollen auf
diesen haushalt werden wird zum schluss
ich will das mal persönlich versuchen zu
sagen bei romeo und julia ist nach
dritte szene du kannst von dem was du
nicht willst nicht reden und eines hat
doch diese debatte gezeigt und das
sollten wir als demokraten den bürgern
doch damit soll ich machen wir fühlen
was das für probleme sind wir sehen was
das für probleme sind und das sag ich
gehe genauso auch für die cdu ich weiß
es nicht ob es sie für die beiden
extremen parteien geht aber wir fühlen
was die mitbürger betrifft und wir
versuchen die möglichst beste lösung und
darüber schreiben wir nicht darüber wer
schlecht oder böse ist herzlichen dank
otto fricke der haushaltspolitische
sprecher der fdp fraktion er hat es
angesprochen die bundesbank auch beim
heute bei der heutigen debatte
lea die ministerpräsidenten aus dem
nordrhein-westfälischen mit der sich
ohnehin in berlin befunden hatte heute
ich hier nicht aber sie sind gefragt
denn sie müssen für das nachfolgeteam
bis neun euro tickets jahr selber noch
geld geben das wird sicherlich noch
verhandlungen geben kerstin radomski
jetzt für die cdu/csu
dass ein ministerpräsident seine
klebrigen finger verliert wenn er
bundeskanzler wird halte ich für steil
aber wir können ja mal schauen ob das
tatsächlich so ist lieber otto bei den
haushaltsberatungen über den etat des
bundeskanzlers möchte ich aber als
erstes mal auf den bereich kultur
eingehen nachdem die bundesregierung nun
neun monate arbeitet muss man sagen jede
regierung hat ihre herausforderungen das
ist so und ich möchte jetzt nicht auf
die debatte zur documenta die wir in den
medien verfolgen konnten eingehen das
macht meine kollegin schenderlein gleich
aber ich möchte doch auf einige
kürzungen um die im etat kultur eingehen
als opposition zu recht fragen kann die
kam es dazu die der beitrag an die
stiftung preußischer kulturbesitz ist um
12 millionen euro gekürzt und vielleicht
bald können sie uns gleich eine antwort
darauf geben wie es kam und dann bin ich
noch über eine zeige stolpert in der
letzten debatte zum haushalt hatten wir
hier eine diskussion auch mit
kurzintervention wo es um eine kürzung
beim humboldt-forum ging und da gab es
doch tatsächlich die these dass da
gekürzt wurde weil man mit
wissenschaftlichen beschriftungen an den
exponaten nicht zufrieden ist und jetzt
stelle ich fest diese kürzung haben sie
nicht zurückgenommen frau
kulturstaatsministerin und da stellt
sich mir und meiner fraktion dann auch
die frage halten sie es genauso wie in
dieser kurzintervention mit dieser
anmerkung dass man beim mit forum kürzen
muss weil die wissenschaftlichen
beschriftung nicht wichtig sind wir
kritisieren zudem dass sie mit zweierlei
maß messen und bei ihnen
erinnerungskultur nicht überall gleich
behandelt wird die aufarbeitung der
kolonialgeschichte ist wichtig aber auch
die ansätze der gedenkstätte deutscher
widerstand und stiftung aufarbeitung sed
werden gekürzt und da fragt man sich
schon ob diese themenfelder für sie
nicht die bedeutung haben wie für uns
als unionsfraktion
und
ihnen auch das thema vertriebene weniger
wert obwohl flucht und vertreibung in
diesen monaten aktueller denn seit
langer zeit sind nachdem der ansatz für
vertriebene im letzten haushalt gekürzt
wurde sinkt er nun um erneut um eine
million euro das ist definitiv eine
fehlentscheidung aus meiner sicht
stattdessen
investieren sie in ihr lieblingsprojekt
wie in culture
das teilt es auf über 15 millionen euro
erhöhten ansatzes für die nachhaltigkeit
ist und ich habe jetzt gehört dass die
ampel koalition viele hilferufe der
filmindustrie erreichen dabei ist
festzustellen dass genau diese branche
die gebeutelte deutsche filmwirtschaft
durch das green shooting finanziell
belastet wird ich zitiere den
geschäftsführer björn böhning bis vor
kurzem noch beamteter staatssekretär in
ihrer bundesregierung der sagt die
aktuelle kostenentwicklung in der
produktions branche in deutschland ist
alarmierend bei der umsetzung von
nachhaltigkeitsstandards die zunehmend
verpflichtet werden gehen wir von
zusätzlichen kosten von bis zu fünf
prozent aus zitat ende naja wenn man das
möchte dann muss das natürlich auch
irgend jemand bezahlen und dann finde
ich es schon erstaunlich dass man dann
von hilferufen aus der filmwirtschaft
spricht aber ich kann an dieser stelle
nur an die ampel appellieren meine damen
und herren bitte überfrachten sie die
kreativen in unserem land nicht noch
weiter mit zusätzlichen regeln und
maßgaben neben dem bereich kultur möchte
ich noch einen kurzen blick auf den
geplanten erweiterungsbau des kampfs
amtes werfen das bundesinnenministerium
prognostizierte doch tatsächlich dass
die kosten auf mindestens 600 millionen
euro statt der veranschlagten
485 millionen euro steigen könnten und
der bundesrechnungshof geht sogar davon
aus dass es noch teurer wird
oppositionsfraktion und als neue
berichterstatterin in diesem einzelplan
frage ich schon seit längerer zeit nach
einem berichterstatter gespräch zu dem
thema in den letzten haushaltsberatungen
war das nicht möglich ich danke aber
nach intensiven einsätzen von otto
fricke dass wir dann morgen endlich ein
gespräch zu dem thema kanzleramt haben
werden ich hoffe für alle parlamentarier
an dieser stelle das nicht schon fakten
geschaffen wurden die dann das parlament
zu ende tragen muss deshalb meine zeit
leicht heißt leider nicht um auf den
ostbeauftragten und die
integrationsbeauftragte einzugehen die
aufwand anwesend sind aber ich hoffe auf
intensive gespräche in den
parlamentarischen beratungen und wünsche
uns dabei allen viel erfolg vielen dank
ps bin hat das wort für die spd fraktion
frau präsidentin herr bundeskanzler
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen meine
sehr verehrten damen und herren seit
sechs monaten für putins russland einen
verbrecherischen krieg gegen die ukraine
und gerade jetzt wenn die auswirkungen
dieses krieges immer größere
herausforderungen für die menschen in
deutschland auch für unsere
volkswirtschaft mit sich bringen ist
unseren debatten eines voranzustellen
die ukraine hat in ihrem freiheitskampf
gegen den russischen adresse unsere
volle unterstützung so lange wie sie
diese unterstützung braucht
putin führt diesen krieg nicht nur auf
den schlachtfeldern er führt ihn auch am
gashahn und mittels des informationen
setzen mit all dem ziel ja darauf ab die
demokratie in dieser welt zu schwächen
und zu spalten doch das werden wir nicht
zulassen
putin dorf und putin wird diesen krieg
nicht gewinnen das ist und bleibt die
erste prämisse der zeitenwende unseres
bundeskanzler
deswegen tun wir in der ampelkoalition
alles um uns aus der abhängigkeit von
russischer energie zu befreien wir lösen
die bremse beim ausbau der erneuerbaren
energien sie sind der schlüssel zu einer
klimaneutralen welt aber eben auch der
schlüssel für unsere souveränität
wir sorgen für zuverlässig die
gaslieferungen aus alternativen quellen
wir treffen vorsorge durch massive
einspeicherung wir nehmen
kohlekraftwerke wieder in betrieb und
der belassen zwei da noch in betrieb
befindlichen atomkraftwerke über das
jahresende hinaus in der reserve ganz
klar ist aber auch ein nochmaliger
ausstieg aus dem atomausstieg ist mit
uns nicht zu machen
die atomkraft ist eine
hochrisikotechnologie in sie produziert
auf jahrtausende strahlen atommüll den
wir nicht sicher sagen können und
deshalb war der atomausstieg vor 22
jahren hat der übrigens stattgefunden
und wurde beschlossen die völlig
richtige entscheidung der regierung von
spd und grünen
zu dieser überzeugung ist nach einer
beispiellosen irrlichter elf jahre
später auch die damals regierende
koalition unter führung der cdu gekommen
eine ähnliche reihe per märz der nun das
parlament leider verlassen hat die
deutsche steuerzahler vertragsstrafen in
milliarden-höhe gekostet hat wir haben
das nicht vergessen haben als sie
offenbar schon
was sie auch gerne vergessen würden wir
es noch im frühjahr es ist schon öfter
gesagt worden forderten sie ein
sofortiges gas im auge für eine kleine
populistische schlagen zeile waren sie
damals bereit die energieversorgungen
damit auch die industrielle produktion
in deutschland in die wand zu fahren
ganz ehrlich von der größten
oppositionspartei hier im parlament
erwarte ich ein bisschen mehr
ernsthaftigkeit wenn es darum geht die
grösste krise zu meistern die dieses
land zu meistern hat
ich sage aber auch ganz deutlich der
jetzt fordert nord stream zwei in
betrieb zu nehmen der den eindruck
vermittelt mit der rückkehr in die arme
die mir putins sei unsere
energieversorgung zu sichern oder die
inflation zu bekämpfen
der spielt dem russischen aggressor
direkt in die hände
meine sehr geehrten damen und herren
unsere bundeskanzler hat mit der
zeitungen aber auch eine zweite prämisse
formuliert wir lassen niemanden allein
denn die folgen von putins
wirtschaftskrieg die unterbrochenen
lieferketten und die steigenden preise
lassen die menschen in deutschland nicht
mehr ruhig schlafen
viele machen sich große sorgen um ihre
lebenshaltung ihren betrieb ihren
arbeitsplatz mit den entscheidungen der
koalition vom vergangenen wochenende
gegen der antwort auf diese berechtigten
sorgen und nöte wir zögen die märkte
weil die mechanismen von angebot und
nachfrage auf den märkten von strom in
alten dame eben nicht mehr funktionieren
sind preise und gewinne außer rand und
band und da hilft es auch nicht das
angebot zu erhöhen unser ziel ist es die
über gewinne abzuschöpfen die einige
derzeit in der energieversorgung machen
und damit einen preis deckel für
brötchen grund bedarf an strom und wärme
zu finanzieren david packen wir die
preisspirale an der wurzel und sorgen
dafür dass energie für die menschen und
für die wirtschaft wieder günstiger wird
oder wir bringen zielgenaue
unterstützung für die menschen für die
wirtschaft auf den weg energieintensive
unternehmen brauchen jetzt unsere hilfe
nicht nur die große industrie auch die
kleinen bäcker und power sorgen sich um
ihre zukunft und dazu kommen
einmalzahlungen färinger innen
studierende ein heizkostenzuschuss zum
wohngeld aber klar ist auch die löhne in
deutschland müssen steigen sechs
millionen beschäftigte werden der
erhöhung des mindestlohns im nächsten
monat profitieren und auch die
tariflöhne müssen jetzt die inflation
abbilden dabei sorgen wir dafür dass den
beschäftigten mehr netto vom brutto
bleibt mit höheren grundfreibeträge
pendler und davos kostenpauschalen
sinken wir für viele die einkommen
steigen weil aber niedrige einkommen
davon kaum profitieren entlasten wir sie
bei den abgaben und zudem befreien wir
auch das wurde schon gesagt inflations
prämien der arbeitgeber von stadt
abgeben das neue wohngeld soll künftig
dreimal so viele haushalte besser
unterstützen wenn wie oft eben das
einkommen für miete und energiekosten
nicht ausreicht und mit dem bürgergeld
sorgen wir neben einer neuen und
nachhaltigen teilhabe förderung auch für
höhere regelsätze
die eben auch die aktuelle inflation
wieder spielen
dazu erhöhen wir noch einmal das
kindergeld in den kinderzuschlag bevor
bevor wir mit der kindergrundsicherung
auch unsere kinder leistungen umfassen
reformieren
meine sehr geehrten damen und herren
lassen niemand allein dafür liefert die
an der regierung mit ihrem dritten
entlastungspaket die richtigen
politischen antworten wir zügeln die
märkte und gewinnen neue kontrolle über
die daseinsvorsorge und die
unterstützten mit zielgenauen hilfen
menschen und betriebe die unsere
unterstützung brauchen zu den
herausforderungen der zeitenwende gehört
es eben auch die grundlagen für den
gesellschaftlichen zusammenhalt in
unserem land zu erneuern und mit dem
haushalt des bundes werden wir dafür die
richtigen weichen stellen
für die art die spricht doktorat jungen
[Applaus]
frau präsidentin meine damen und herren
keine regierung seit bestehen der
bundesrepublik deutschland hat unser
land so sehr an den rand des abgrunds
geführt wie diese sogenannte ampel
regierung und da hat die cdu in den
unseligen merkel jahren auch kräftig
vorarbeit mit geleistet deshalb ist es
heuchlerisch was herr merz wir heute
geboten hat
nachdem für die wirtschaft verheerenden
corona maßnahmen stecken wir jetzt in
einer großen als hausgemachten
energiekrise mit explodierenden
heizkosten bei galoppieren der inflation
es droht der große blackout und das
große frieren in diesem winter das ist
die industrienationen deutschland im
jahr 1922 20 22 und dass es direkte
folge ihrer fehlentscheidungen dass es
ihre aller verantwortung
die süddeutsche zeitung sprach von einer
bevorstehenden triage der mittel
zuwendungen und man kann sich leicht
ausmalen wem als erstes licht und
heizung abgedreht wird ich zitiere frau
staatsministerin claudia roth
kultureinrichtungen können eine
vorbildfunktion übernehmen und sagen ja
wir haben verstanden wir müssen einen
beitrag leisten kim jong-un hätte es
nicht besser sagen können die kultur ist
das erste opfer ihrer ideologischen
verblendung meine damen und herren und
wo die bonner politik und die
energiekrise nicht hinreichend mit ihrem
zerstörungswerk da hilft die
bundesregierung nach indem sie
kulturgüter aus deutschen museen ins
ausland einfach verschenkt anfang juli
haben frau roth und frau bär burg mit
nigeria ein abkommen unterzeichnet über
die rückgabe aller sogenannten berlin
großen kunstwerke im wert von mehreren
hundert millionen euro ohne
rechtsgrundlage aber natürlich mit hypo
moralischem sendungs und bücher
bewusstsein und was ist geschehen
es ist dadurch jetzt ein streit
entbrannt zwischen dem nigerianischen
staat und dem königshaus berlin massive
gewaltandrohungen stehen im raum die
restitution study group in new york
nachfahren von im heutigen nigeria
verkraften menschen fordern sie dazu auf
die branchen in deutschen museen zu
belassen dass ich in nigeria einen
falschen hände in falsche hände geraten
das kommt davon wenn studienabbrecher
historische gerechtigkeit herzustellen
versuchen das geht gründlich in die hose
vor der sommerpause hatten wir hier über
den antisemitismus skandal auf der
documenta gesprochen jetzt hat ein
dortiger von ihnen geförderter
aktivisten künstler aus bangladesch sie
herr bundeskanzler scholz ich zitiere
als faschistisches schwein bezeichnet
nachdem sie dessen antisemitisches
machwerk pflichtschule kritisiert hatten
da sieht man wie die nazikeule zum
bumerang werden kann und ihren erfindern
einen nackten stoß versetzt die
förderung dieses linksradikalen
aktivismus unter dem deckmantel der
kunst muss aufhören aber davon ist in
ihrem haushalt noch nichts zu spüren
meine damen und herren bestehen können
solche protesten zustände nur dank eines
öffentlich rechtlichen rundfunks der den
regierungen nach der pfeife tanzt die
bürger aber permanent bevormundet und zu
einer politisch korrekten walken haltung
erzielt welche haltung in weiten teilen
der ard tatsächlich herrscht das haben
die skandale in rbb ndr und anderen
gezeigt eine gruppe
selbstbedienungsmentalität von
spitzenverdienern die sogenannte
demokratie abgabe der gebührenzahler
wird in privatflüge sind eure büroetagen
und massagesessel gesteckt was für ein
zynismus meine damen und herren und zum
stichwort zionismus passt auch dass die
integrationsbeauftragte des bundes nach
beauftragte für antirassismus geworden
ist der sogenannte anti rassismus stellt
deutsche unter generalverdacht schiebt
das scheitern der integration auf den
angeblichen rassismus der
mehrheitsgesellschaft und er fördert die
spaltung der gesellschaft in dem er die
einzelnen gruppen gegeneinander aufhetzt
und jeden kritiker dieser politik als
rechtsextremisten diffamiert ihre
bilanzwerte achtel parteien fällt
verheerend aus wir werden unsere
änderungsvorschläge im ausschuss
präsentieren
für die bundesregierung hat die
staatsministerin claudia roth jetzt das
wort genau den teil des kanzler etats
ist eben auch der etat für die
beauftragte der bundesregierung für
kultur und medien
zusammen zu stehen
gemeinsame werte zu teilen und
teilzuhaben an gesellschaftlichen
politischen und kulturellen
entwicklungen und entscheidungen das
verstehe ich unter einer demokratischen
kultur diese kultur sie macht uns aus
und diese kultur werden wir verteidigen
nur wer teil hat am gesellschaftlichen
politischen am kulturellen leben wird
auch gemeinsame demokratische werte
teilen eben das macht deutlich in
welchem verhältnis kultur gesellschaft
und politik zueinanderstehen es zeigt
dass museen das theater ist das kinos
das konzert zähle dass literatur dass
musik das kunst kein nice to have sind
sondern ein wesentliches ein
konstituierendes moment demokratischer
gesellschaften
kultureinrichtungen sind dritte orte
orte der bildung oder der begegnung der
sozialen wärme und der gemeinschaft sie
sind von immenser bedeutung gerade in
krisenzeiten und wir leben nicht nur in
einer krise wir erleben wie ein krieg
aus einer krise folgt und wieder neue
krisen ausgelöst wir sehen wie die
herausforderungen sich in und
übereinander schieben wie tektonische
platten als wäre das nicht genug
treibt der krieg gegen die ukraine uns
vor sich her vernichtet existenzen
zerstört kultureinrichtungen dort jeder
menschlichen ordnung mit auslöschung
mein ukrainischer amtskollege alexander
djatschenko hat mir erst vor wenigen
tagen von den über 500 beschädigten oder
systematisch zerstörten ukrainischen
kultureinrichtungen berichtet
bibliotheken theater konzertsäle dem
müssen und dem werden wir uns
entgegenstellen
wir werden als demokratinnen und
demokraten
zusammenstehen aus respekt vor den
menschen in der ukraine die sich
behaupten müssen in einem krieg gegen
die demokratie in einem krieg gegen die
kultur und sie kämpfen ja nicht nur für
sich selbst sie kämpfen auch für uns für
ein freies und für ein demokratisches
europa wer nur zuschaut wie die kultur
der ukraine zerstört wird gibt nicht nur
dieses land und seine menschen auch
ergibt sich selber auf kultur ist die
grundlage unseres zusammenlebens wer
zulässt dass die anderenorts mutwillig
zerstört wird gibt sie preis und
deswegen muss beim wiederaufbau der
ukraine auch die kultur mitgedacht
werden
wir wollen wir werden die kultur und
fördern und erhalten eben weil sie es
ist jens es essentiell ist für ein
gelingendes zusammenleben
wir wollen sie vor nach und zwischen den
krisen fördern und erhalten die kultur
erhebt mit aus eigenem recht anspruch
darauf und damit auch auf eine teilhabe
am gemeinsamen budget die zeit drängt
und wir werden im kommenden winter
öffentliche wie private
kultureinrichtungen unterstützen müssen
die auch unter den massiv gestiegenen
energiepreisen besonders zu leiden haben
wir wollen keinen weiteren winter vor
geschlossenen kinos und theater türen
sehen auf konzerte und lesungen
verzichten und daher wollen wir zur
bewältigung der rapide steigenden
energiekosten die kultureinrichtungen in
deutschland zielgerichtet sehr
zielgerichtet mit einer milliarde euro
unterstützen
das heißt wir wollen nicht zurück in
eine energieabhängigkeit die europa die
unser politisches system unsere art zu
leben unsere demokratische kultur und
obendrein noch unsere lebensgrundlagen
bedroht wir wollen auch im kulturbereich
nachhaltig wirtschaften und wer das will
muss vorausschauend handeln und das
haben wir getan als wir mit green
culture im koalitionsvertrag die weichen
gemeinsam in eine nachhaltige zukunft
der kulturbranche gestellt haben noch
bevor die auswirkungen des krieges als
energie krise auf uns zurückschlugen und
deswegen haben wir es getan mit der
einrichtung eines eigenen referats eines
teams für nachhaltigkeit in der kultur
mit vorausschauenden beratungen durch
die bundesnetzagentur und mit vielen
gesprächen die wir mit dem
kulturminister innen der länder und mit
den kommunen führen wir haben nicht nur
erwartungen an die betreiber von kino
sun theater oder an opernhäuser
formuliert sondern wir werden sie auch
schützen und wir werden sie unterstützen
ja es waren schwierige
haushaltsverhandlungen
gemeinsam mit dem finanzminister dem ich
an dieser stelle herzlich danken möchte
ist es uns aber gelungen einen aufwuchs
im kulturhaushalt zu erreichen und dass
das ist in diesen zeiten alles andere
als selbstverständlich
mein dank geht aber auch den kolleginnen
und kollegen aus dem kulturausschuss
mein dank gilt den haushälter innen und
haushältern mit herz für die kultur für
eine wirklich außerordentlich
konstruktive zusammenarbeit und liebe
frau von dem ski der haushaltsausschuss
hat die mittel nicht gestrichen sondern
für die spk und das humboldt-forum
gesperrt nicht zuletzt um einen
reformprozess voranzubringen
zusammen stehen
das heißt für mich dass wir die
demokratischen kräfte von kunst und
kultur von meinungs- und pressefreiheit
dort entfesseln werden wo unser
demokratisches
gesellschaftsmodell angegriffen wird
zusammenstehen heißt für mich auch dass
sich
antisemitismus-vorwürfe gegen die
dokumente sehr sehr ernst nehme und
natürlich konsequenzen ziehe das
bedeutet auch dass sich etwas an den
strukturen der documenta ändern muss und
zusammenstehen das heißt dass sich
maßnahmen gegen rassismus
antiziganismus und quer feindlichkeit
für die förderung unserer demokratie
auch und gerade mit dem kulturbereich
unterstütze ich will dass dieser winter
der solidarität auch ein winter der
kultur wird und setze auf ihre
unterstützung
claudia roth war dass die beauftragte
der bundesregierung für kultur und
medien
und sie hat es noch einmal betont mit
dem entlastungspaket der bundesregierung
soll ja auch die kulturszene unterstützt
werden beispielsweise kultur richtungen
die unter auch den gestiegenen
energiekosten leiden
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen ich bin
sehr froh dass ich nach so guten
nachrichten des vorangegangenen
kulturetats noch einmal ein wirkliches
liegen entwurf sehen im
regierungsentwurf für 2023 steigt der
kultur etat und 19 5 millionen und damit
um knapp ein prozent für mich die selbst
aus der branche kommt und die sorgen und
nöte der kulturschaffenden kennt wie
kaum jemand hier sind das sehr
erfreuliche nachrichten was sich bei dem
entwurf besonders positiv auffällt ist
dass sich der stellenwert der kultur in
unserem land und in unserer gesellschaft
deutlich verbessert hat die
kunstfreiheit ist ein hohes gut und
freiräume für kunst zu schaffen ist eine
aufgabe für uns alle ich sehe mit
programm verstetigung und neue titel die
dazu beitragen für kunst und
kulturschaffender rahmenbedingungen zu
ermöglichen
hier denke ich mit blick auf die
außenpolitische lag besonders an
journalisten exil geflüchtete kulturen
medienschaffende die allein mit sechs
millionen euro unterstützt werden kunst
und kultur sind lebenselixier
spätestens seit beginn der pandemie hat
jeder einzelne von uns gestellt wie
elementar unser leben von kultur im
allgemeinen begleitet wird es hat uns
auch der zeigt wie vielfältig die
kulturlandschaft eigentlich aufgestellt
ist und die barrierefrei der zugang zu
kulturellen leben bisher für uns war die
regierungskoalition hat sich vorgenommen
kultur als staatsziel im grundgesetz zu
verankern das ist ein tiefes bekenntnis
zur kultur und markiert ihren
stellenwert in unserer gesellschaft sehr
deutlich daher zeigt sich für die ampel
ist immer klar kultur ist kein
schmuckstück für gute tage kultur ist
das was uns umgibt und uns ausmacht
[Applaus]
sie braucht daher perspektive und vor
allem planungssicherheit
dafür soll sie unsere volle
unterstützung unterhalten
mit dem tollen programm neustadt
gestohlen dem sonderfonds des bundes für
kulturveranstaltungen haben wir bereits
eine wichtige grundlage gelegt vor allem
nichtstaatlichen einrichtungen und
projekten wurde damit finanziell
geholfen
allerdings sieht sich die kulturbranche
nach überstandener erster runde mit dem
nächsten problem konfrontiert sie leidet
unter ihrer ganz eigenen form von longo
bit halbleere veranstaltungshallen und
festivals fehlendes fachpersonal keine
absicherung zukünftiger veranstaltungs
ausfalle rasant steigende kosten die
angst der menschen vor der
wirtschaftskrise die hoffnung der
deutschen kultur veranstaltungsbranche
dass es nach zwei jahren lockt dann
wieder aufwärts geht steht auf ganz
dünnem eis
zweieinhalb jahre nachdem lockdown ist
die kultur noch immer der am härtesten
von der pandemie betroffene
wirtschaftszweig noch dazu ist sie
weiterhin nähe von einer rückkehr auf
das vorkrisenniveau entfernt
das bedeutet ganz klar die hilfen der
bundesregierung dürfen hier nicht enden
und der kultur etat ist an dieser stelle
genau so existenziell wie im vergangenen
jahr deshalb werden wir hier auf nahtlos
anknüpfen aber wir sehen auch ganz
deutlich dass das bkm meiner
einschätzung nach die probleme dieser
branche im blick behält und mit ihrem
haushaltsentwurf dankenswerter weise
vorsorge getroffen hat das
rettungspaketen neustadt kultur wurde
zunächst bis juni 2023 verlängert und
die sondermittel aus dem programm erneut
aufgestockt darüber hinaus stehen
bereits weitere 15,1 millionen euro für
die förderung der kultur und
kreativwirtschaft und der nachhaltigkeit
in kulturen medien zur verfügung das
lässt mich tief durchatmen auf gleiches
leider auf weiß dass wir hier weiterhin
mammut aufgabe vor uns haben und dem
prozess auch langfristig parlamentarisch
begleiten werden damit unser kulturelles
leben überleben und ich denke hierbei
geehrte damen und herren sind wir uns
ausnahmsweise und unbestritten alle
einig vielen dank an
den märkten war dass die hierfür die im
liberalen gesprochen hat als
kulturpolitische sprecherin und als
nächst höhere liga war die kulisse für
die cdu csu fraktion deren
stellvertretenden fraktionsvorsitzenden
johann barth folien kollegen die debatte
über den kanzleretat die sogenannte
generaldebatte ist grundsätzlich auch
immer gelegenheit über die außen europa
sicherheitspolitik der bundesregierung
und des bundeskanzlers zu diskutieren
und hatte mir vorgenommen zu den
ausfällen des bundeskanzlers an dieser
stelle etwas zu sagen er hat praktisch
nichts gesagt außer einigen wenigen
sätzen zur ukraine das ist enttäuschend
genug wir haben eine veritable krise um
taiwan wir haben eine veritable
krisensituation in der sahel-zone die
verteidigungsministerin stellt den
einsatz der bundeswehr im grunde in
frage die außenministerin plädiert
nachhaltig dafür den einsatz der
bundeswehr dort fortzusetzen
es gibt geradezu tektonische
verschiebungen in der weltgemeinschaft
wo autokratische staaten wie china aber
auch russland das was wir die
internationale regelbasierte ort punkt
nennen immer weiter in frage stellen und
der bundeskanzlei hinterlässt an dieser
stelle eine lehrstelle das ist
unzureichend das wird der
internationalen europäischen
verantwortung der bundesrat nicht
gerecht der bundeskanzler
stattdessen halten sie hier die rede im
grunde eines generalsekretärs der spd
mit angriffen gegen die union die ihren
eigenen ansprüchen und den ansprüchen
ihres fraktionsvorsitzenden der für
ernsthaftigkeit und gegen sprücheklopfen
hier vorhin geredet hat nicht gerecht
werden wer der union pauschal
unterstellt in der energiepolitik
versagt zu haben sollte nicht in abrede
stellen dass er in der letzten
legislaturperiode als vizekanzler und im
übrigen seit es die als spd seit 1998
mit der ausnahme von vier jahren
verantwortung für die energiepolitik
dieses landes und natürlich auch für
eine beklagenswerte abhängigkeit von
russland hat sie sitzen im glashaus
meine sehr verehrten damen und herren
und das gilt auch wenn die grünen frau
kollegin hatte man das nicht wahrhaben
wollen auch für ihre fraktionen ihre
partei denn nord stream 1 das vergessen
sie jetzt immer wieder wurde unter rot
grün mit bundeskanzler schröder begonnen
sie waren dabei sie haben das mitgemacht
wir sitzen alle in so fern in einem
glashaus und müssen gemeinsam eine neue
energiepolitik für die zukunft aufbauen
aber hier eine geschichte zu erzählen
dass hier nur eine fraktion und eine
partei dafür verantwortlich sei da
machen sie es sich zu leicht und aus
dieser verantwortung werden wir sie auch
für die zukunft nicht
entlassen und den freien demokraten sei
gesagt hier auf bundesebene eine politik
mit zu tragen
die dafür sorgt dass gerade das
kernkraftwerk in niedersachsen nicht
wieder genutzt wird und im
niedersächsischen landtagswahlkampf
politik dafür zu machen dass wenn man
fdp wählt das wenn man fdp wählt die
kernenergie wieder genutzt wird also ich
meine das ist ein taschenspielertrick
den märkten die bürgerinnen und bürger
wie war das eigentlich noch mit schlecht
regieren und lieber nicht regieren
überlegen sie sich das noch mal
sortieren sie sich an der stelle
aufrichtigkeit und klarheit würde
belohnt werden sie wackeln so um die
fünf prozent so würde ich nicht
weitermachen als liberale sie gefährden
sich und damit frau zimmermann bin ich
bei der ukraine bei der aussage von frau
s gehen die vorher noch einmal gesagt
hat wir stehen
die ukraine hat sie wörtlich gesagt hat
unsere volle unterstützung
dazu gehört dann auch die umsetzung des
beschlusses des deutschen bundestages
schwere waffen zu liefern und sie
vorschlag zimmermann haben hier
ergebnislos dem bundeskanzler ein
ultimatum gesetzt ein panzer ultimatum
wie das genannt wurde nun endlich marder
schützenpanzer zu liefern es geschieht
nicht stattdessen zieht sich der
bundeskanzler dahinter zurück und sagt
da geht es irgendwie eine vereinbarung
mit bündnispartner den vereinigten
staaten das dass
sie haben ihn wenn ihr radl weise
liebevoll aufgefordert die
öffentlichkeit nimmt ihre liebevolle
zuwendung immer gleich als ultimatum war
so ist das mit eigenen wahrnehmung und
stadtplanung aber ich will das mal in
aller ernsthaftigkeit sagen was passiert
ja eigentlich das ist ja nicht nur toni
hofreiter oder marie agnes strack
zimmermann die jetzt hier mehrfach dafür
plädiert haben dass der
bundestagsbeschluss punkt für punkt
umgesetzt wird und da steht nicht drin
schwere waffen exklusive maria und
leopard 1 sondern die sind davon umfasst
es ist nicht irgendeine platte frei es
gehen es geht darum ob die ukraine in
einem überlebenskampf eine chance hat
und darum geht es oder um es mit ralf
fücks zu sagen dem aal grünen diese
lieferungen könnten den unterschied
zugunsten der freiheit machen das ist
der punkt deutschland könnte in dieser
systeme auseinandersetzung den
unterschied machen und da gibt es auch
forderungen aus den koalitionsfraktionen
von den sprecherinnen von grünen fdp und
auch ein mitglied der spd aus dem
verteidigungsausschuss sogar aus dem
bestand der bundeswehr zu liefern das
geht über das hinaus was wir sogar
bisher beschlossen haben der
bundeskanzler macht nichts sie sind in
ihrer unterstützung der ukraine
halbherzig wenn die sache scheitert wenn
die ukraine an der stelle keinen erfolg
hat wenn es jeden tag länger kritik dann
ist das ihre verantwortung die sie
gemeinsam tragen meine sehr verehrten
johann wadephul war das für die cdu csu
fraktion ja die außen- verteidigungs-
und sicherheitspolitik die spielt
natürlich nicht nur hier bei der debatte
bei der generaldebatte eine rolle
sondern auch am nachmittag deswegen noch
der hinweis es folgt dann nämlich auch
der einzelplan außen und der einzelplan
verteidigung also ein interessanter tag
hier am zweiten tag der
haushaltsberatung im bundestag
und den dortigen energie erpressern
fraternisierung wie sie der sollte
angesichts der energiemarkt bei
kulturmedien eines tun beschämt das
haupt zu senken und einfach die klappe
halten das wahrnehmen der gipfel der
scheinheiligkeit
ihrerseits wer liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen wer
gesellschaftliche fortschritt und
modernität nicht nur als technologischen
fortschritt begreift der will und
braucht starke kultur und starke medien
und weil das so ist ist jetzt auch der
moment gekommen dank zu sagen dank
zusammen insbesondere den
kulturschaffenden die nicht nur in den
aktuellen krisen sondern oft seit
jahrzehnten oft unter prekären
arbeitsbedingungen genau das tun nämlich
in diesem labor gesellschaftlicher
modernität zu arbeiten und dabei auch
noch sehr innovative formen der
solidarität und kollaboration zu finden
und dabei eben nicht zu lamentieren
sondern zu handeln dank wie ihnen danke
euch für diese arbeit ja das ist arbeit
und deshalb
ist das was wir tun eben auch keine
wohltätigkeit kein almosen und auch kein
mäzenatentum sondern es ist schlicht
pflicht pflicht die folgt aus dem
deutschen sozialstaat und kulturstadt
und deshalb halte ich es auch für
angebracht wenn wir zu recht viel zu
selten von kommunaler daseinsvorsorge
sprechen eben auch von kultureller
daseinsvorsorge zu sprechen denn darum
geht es geht nicht um ein addon einem
ornament sondern es geht um das
elementare und wenn wir dann den
vorsorgenden sozialstaat beschworen
haben viel mehr beschweren sollten
heutzutage dann finde ich sollten wir
auch vom vorsorgenden kulturstadt
sprechen so wichtig ist die frage von
der wir sprechen und deshalb ist es auch
eine gute nachricht
das wiederum der kulturhaushalt
gestiegen ist und stabilisiert werden
konnte gerade in der krise und in der
situation des sparens und deshalb ist
auch größter respekt tschuldigung dem
finanzminister dem kanzler und auch der
staatsministerin dass sie es
unbürokratisch möglich gemacht haben
dass eine milliarde ungefähr aus dem
sonderfonds eingesetzt werden kann für
eben diese energie not im bereich kultur
und medien
und wenn es uns dann auch noch gelingt
das mit einer gewissen bürokratischen
enthaltsamkeit und administrativen diät
umzusetzen im zusammenspiel mit kommunen
und ländern dann ist den betroffenen
noch mehr geholfen und dabei geht es
eben nicht nur um
professionelle kulturschaffenden sondern
eben auch um den ganzen bereich der
amateur kunst der chöre der
kulturvereine all der vielen für die die
bedrohung durch die energiekrise eine
essentielle bedrohung ist wenn wir aber
das erlaube ich mir auch zu sagen wenn
wir kulturellen fortschritt wollen der
eben weit mehr ist als das aufzählen
kultureller tanker wie ich in einigen
konservativen kultur reden eben
vernommen habe dann ist das eben gerade
nicht das was der zoologisch muss also
logische 3 satz von herrn merkstein
präsentiert der ging ungefähr
folgendermaßen start ist marktwirtschaft
ich bin die marktwirtschaft ergo bin ich
der staat l'etat c'est moi das ist aber
kein kultureller fortschritt dass auch
keine politik dass es abwesenheit von
politik wo es da ernst wo ist die
bevölkerung und wo ist da eine idee ich
entdecke sie nicht deshalb
wollen wir kultur medienpolitik mit idee
und mit der bevölkerung und wollen wir
eben diesen vorsorgen kultur und
sozialstaat in der das was die
kulturschaffenden leisten eben begriffen
wird als das was es ist harte
gesellschaftliche und kulturelle arbeit
die auch der entsprechende absicherung
unterstützung bedarf und wir sind
gefordert dass nicht nur jetzt in der
krise sondern auch künftig
sicherzustellen und uns ein beispiel zu
nehmen an ebendiesen kulturschaffenden
die nicht lamentiert haben über
jahrzehnte sondern die gehandelt haben
und die uns ein beispiel in dem fall
gesehen sind was aber nicht sein
und auch das konservative fiskalpolitik
was nicht sein kann ist das reiche
kommen und dort wo er habe menschen sich
kultur leisten legen aber in armen
kommunen kultur zum luxus wird das ist
kein tief unbedingt ja das ist
buchstäblich asozial nämlich sind szenen
schildern
er hat grunde hat das wort für bündnis
90/die grünen
präsidentin meine damen und herren
22 jahre strenge lager hofft dazu ist
gerade der russische journalist über
einen savran oft verurteilt worden
angeblich wegen hochverrats sein
hochverrat besteht darin aus kritik
berichterstattung zu machen
berichterstattung über das was als basis
einer freien meinungsbildung grundlage
jeder freien gesellschaft ist und das
ist in russland derzeit unerwünscht
stattdessen gibt es putins propaganda
märchen frei haus wer den abgleich
zwischen feld und fakten derart fürchtet
er fürchtet die offene freiheitliche
gesellschaft der fürchtet die demokratie
derzeit verbreitet der russische staat
weltweit gezielte desinformation
letztendlich mit dem ziel unsere
demokratien gezielt zu destabilisieren
und das dürfen und werden wir niemals
zulassen
und so wichtiger sind die programme von
staatsministerin claudia roth trotz
angespannter haushaltslage im
regierungsentwurf mit entsprechenden
finanzmitteln unterlegt hat
es geht darum medienschaffende mit sechs
millionen die unter anderem journalisten
darunter unterstützen aus dem exil
heraus unabhängige berichterstattung für
die menschen in ihre herkunftsländer zu
tätigen
lassen sie mich in einer
medienpolitischen debatte auch folgendes
ansprechen bleischwer wegen derzeit die
vorwürfe der vetternwirtschaft der
vorteilsnahme und sogar der
einflussnahme auf die berichterstattung
in zwei sendern des öffentlich
rechtlichen rundfunks
diese vorwürfe müssen lückenlos
aufgeklärt werden es kann nicht
hingenommen werden dass diese
gravierenden fehler in den
führungsetagen das vertrauen in die
arbeit der journalistinnen und
journalisten der öffentlich-rechtlichen
sender untergraben entscheidend ist
jetzt dass die aufsichtsgremien deutlich
gestärkt werden das sehen auch die
reformvorschläge neben den staatsvertrag
vor es geht vor allem um die herstellung
von transparenz eine klare fehleranalyse
und eine zügige umsetzung des
reformprozesses da werden wir nicht
lockerlassen
was wir aber auch nicht zu lassen ist
der versuch die fehler einzelner zu
instrumentalisieren um zum großen
kehraus gegen den öffentlich rechtlichen
rundfunk anzusetzen ich wende mich
dagegen dass immer wieder abgeordnete
des bundestags in interviews mit
vermeintlich guten ratschlägen bei der
programmgestaltung aufwarten der
öffentlich rechtliche rundfunk ist als
unabhängige institution der
entscheidende faktor für ein starkes
diverse hochwertiges angebot auch gerade
weil hier die journalistin im interview
mit dem politiker eben nicht mit ihrem
brötchengeber spricht der öffentlich
rechtliche rundfunk beitrag finanziert
und föderal organisiert markiert einen
qualitätsstandard und den uns die welt
beneidet von wissen macht ah bis zur
tagesschau ja von meischberger
böhmermann wir werden alles dafür tun
dass es so bleibt vielen dank
der gründe war dass der traktor
medienpolitischer sprecher der
bündnisgrünen
so nächste hier am rednerpult
lindert wollte er noch das
generaldebatte die hier ja auch ungefähr
vier stunden angesetzt ist die linda
teuteberg die ist mitglied im
innenausschuss spricht für die fdp
präsidentin liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen als heute vor 35 jahren der
damalige bundeskanzler kohl in der
bonner redoute in anwesenheit seines
staatsgastes erich honecker von der
ungebrochenen bewusstsein für die
einheit der nation vom
verfassungsauftrag der wiedervereinigung
und auch von der sehnsucht der menschen
in ost und west nacheinander sprach da
war noch nichts zu ahnen trotz michael
gorbatschow dessen wir heute zu recht
gedacht haben wo er längst auf der
weltbühne war und wirkte der sowjetunion
was ab dem 4 september 1989 in leipzig
stattfinden würde wo bürgerinnen und
bürger mit der parole für ein offenes
land mit freien menschen sich warten auf
die straße zu gehen für elementare
bürgerrechte
demonstrierten denn in der zwischenzeit
hatte die sed in der ddr zum beispiel
das magazin sputnik verboten
insbesondere weil dort die geschichte
aufgearbeitet wurde und zb offen über
den hitler stalin pakt geschrieben wurde
und deshalb ist es und das kann man der
linken nicht ersparen schon nicht mehr
nur zu vergessen sondern zynisch wenn
sie mit dem mythos der friedlichen
revolution in leipzig hier politisches
kapital schlagen wollen der s symbol
dieses protestes war die friedfertigkeit
der kerze und nicht die geballte faust
und für ein offenes land mit freien
menschen dafür kämpfen heute auf die
menschen in der ukraine und deshalb ist
es richtig dass wir sie unterstützen
an der seite unserer verbündeten und
heute fordern uns soziale verwerfungen
heraus die in folge des russischen
angriffskrieges infolge der energiekrise
und der inflation die wiederum ihre
eigene politische vorgeschichte haben
auf die ich nicht eingehen kann unsere
gesellschaft vor eine harte probe
stellen und liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen wenn und weil wir nicht
zulassen wollen dass die politischen
ränder hier politische zu- und
zufalls und über gewinne einstreichen
müssen wir uns der verantwortung stellen
hierfür lösungen zu finden
und da sage ich für unsere ganze
republik aber insbesondere für die
menschen in ostdeutschland die vor 30
jahren zum ersten mal in die situation
kam die chancen der marktwirtschaft zu
nutzen und sie genutzt haben viele die
sich selbstständig gemacht haben wisag
aus aktuellem anlass auch die
bäckerinnen und bäcker in unserem land
die nicht erwarten staatliche wohltaten
zu bekommen sondern eine zuverlässige
und bezahlbare energieversorgung
die träumen nicht von einem bullerbü in
dem der strom aus der steckdose und
wohlstand aus der geldpresse kommt
sondern darf die erwarten dass wir jetzt
alle hebel nutzen für die
energieversorgung in unserem land alle
auch dazu gehören alle technologien und
möglichkeiten die wir haben und zwar aus
jetzt zur verfügung stehenden
atomkraftwerke
das ist jetzt zu tun und zwar
unverzüglich
gott christiane stelle das ist die
nächste rednerin für die cdu csu
fraktion
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin sehr
geehrte kolleginnen und kollegen wir
alle konnten in diesem sommer die kultur
wieder genießen aber der schein trügt
die kultur befindet sich in einer
dauerkrise viele konzerte sind einfach
corona bedingt nachgeholt wurden sie
sind nicht ausverkauft oder auch
namhafte bands wie revolverheld sie
sagen ihre geplanten tourneen wieder ab
es fehlt schlicht und ergreifend an
planungssicherheit bei der
aktualisierung des
infektionsschutzgesetzes
sollen die möglichkeit bestehen personen
obergrenzen für das publikum wieder
festzulegen und genau das schafft diese
unsicherheit der kulturbereich hat mit
unglaublich viel aufwand in diesem
bereich hygiene und schutzkonzepte
entwickelt und in vielen fällen trägt
sich nur die vollauslastung
das heißt auch im dritten corinna winter
wird diese branche weiterhin auf
unterstützung angewiesen sein die kultur
leitet und ordnung vor wird und niemand
wird sie an professor mischung vom
bundesverband der
veranstaltungswirtschaft klagt an ich
zitiere die regierung ist derzeit
überhaupt nicht bereit darüber zu
verhandeln
alle bereiche der kultur und
kreativwirtschaft stellen derzeit fest
dass die politik ganz offenbar mit
verbänden nicht mehr reden will und
unsere forderung nach gesprächen mit der
branche wurde im ausschuss wiederholt
ignoriert und zum wiederholten male muss
ich an dieser stelle sagen dass es noch
immer keine ansprechpartner für die
kultur und kreativwirtschaft in der
bundesregierung gibt und zusätzlich
verstärkt wird diese aktuelle situation
durch die energiekrise der deutsche
kulturrat hat die bundesregierung
bereits im juni aufgefordert im haushalt
23 die etats für nebenkosten vom bundes
kultureinrichtungen zu erhöhen die
forderung blieb ungehört
stattdessen will man jetzt restmittel
vom sonderfonds für
kulturveranstaltungen
zweckentfremden eine milliarde euro geld
das eigentlich für den ausfall von
kulturveranstaltungen vorgesehen ist es
ist ganz klar sie wollen hier eigenes
versagen verschleiern und dabei droht im
winter eine schließungswelle vor allem
bei den kleinen einrichtungen und
vereine und die kulturangebote vor allem
im ländlichen raum sind dabei so wichtig
deshalb hatten wir auch
fraktionsübergreifend das
zukunftsprogramm kino in den letzten
haushaltsberatungen aufgestockt und
jetzt fehlt dieses geld wieder diese
zehn millionen euro
eine krise erfordert krisen-management
doch sie frau staatsministerin roth
schweigen exemplarisch hierfür steht der
documenta skandal die dokumente bietet
seit mitte juni eine bühne für
antisemitische und deutschland
feindliche hetze judenhass darf nicht
mit deutschem steuergeld finanziert
werden
erst gestern
sprach der israelische staatspräsident
herz hüpft ihr an dieser stelle über die
historische verantwortung deutschlands
und stadt klar stellung zu beziehen
schweigen sie verroht genauso wie der
bundeskanzler wenn der
palästinenserpräsident im kanzleramt
behauptet israel habe seit 1947 50 form
across an palästinensern begangen sie
dürfen diesen dokumenten skandal nicht
aussitzen ja sie tragen als geldgeber
wenn eine mitverantwortung stellen sie
sich dieser verantwortung die drei
millionen euro bundes und steuermitteln
müssten zurückgefordert werden und
künftige förderung mitte zu sagen dürfen
nur dann erfolgen wenn eine
distanzierung des wortes bewegung
erfolgt ist youtube die tendenz der
kulturbetrieb dürfen nicht länger
geduldet werden und wir hätten uns auch
ein kritisches wort gewünscht von
infrarot als sich klimaaktivisten
ankaufs gemälde in berlin da ist nun
frankfurt geklebt haben bilder die zu
unserem kulturellen welterbe gehören
wurden beschädigt das ist 1000 wer kommt
für diesen schaden auf
[Applaus]
das sind viele erklärte vorhaben und
ankündigung der regierung aber es gibt
kein plenum kultur kein un
sonderbeauftragten für den schutz
familien schafften keinen
ansprechpartner für die
kreativwirtschaft wo liegen ihre
prioritäten das mahnmal für die opfer
des kommunismus scheint nicht der fall
zu sein denn sonst hätten sie diesen
standort denn der kulturausschuss schon
lange
abgelehnt hat hier nicht vorgeschlagen
das heißt die ampel regierung lässt
ihren großen ankündigungen bisher keine
taten folgen dabei wäre es fatal wenn
der bisherige kurs nicht an der kultur
zu sparen aufgekündigt wird daher werden
wir in der haushaltsberatung im
kulturausschuss genau hinsehen und wir
erwarten antworten auf unsere fragen
vielen dank
daher die kritik und auch die
ankündigung von christiane schlendern
leyen für die cdu/csu-fraktion was dann
auch in den haushaltsberatungen kommt
auch wenn es um den etat für kultur
medien gilt der teil des kanzlers ist so
wären auch platz für die spd die
stellvertretende fraktionsvorsitzende
er gehört der bundeskanzler liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
bundeskanzler olaf scholz hat im juli
den satz you never walk alone gesagt ich
bin fußballfan bekennender fan des 1 fc
kaiserslautern eintracht trier habe das
lied schon oft mit gesungen unter
anderem in der westkurve und ich hab mal
überlegt was bedeutet das eigentlich was
bedeutet dass auch für mich ganz konkret
das bedeutet mehr als wir gehen
nebeneinander denn wir gehen miteinander
wir schauen nach einander und wir lassen
niemanden zurück in dem songtext geht es
auch um hoffnung und mut und das ist
auch genau das signal dass wir jetzt mit
dem dritten entlastungspaket gemeinsam
senden es ist kein flickenteppich und
kein will und rott und kein forderungs
wettbewerb den wir da vorgelegt haben
nach der sommerpause sondern wir haben
konzentriert gearbeitet über die
arbeitsgemeinschaften der fraktion mit
den parteien mit der regierung zusammen
und wir haben hier ein schlüssiges
gesamtkonzept vorgelegt und ich finde
und das kann man hier auch mal sagen
haushaltsdebatten sind leidenschaftliche
olaf scholz hat das eben hier als
bundeskanzler ganz genau auch richtig
eingebracht denn in dieser zeit geht es
um mut es geht um krise es geht aber vor
allen dingen um weitsicht und dass wir
hier auch das land cruiser führen und
dafür danke ich in diesen schwierigen
zeiten
aber es geht uns natürlich auch darum
wer die ganze sache bezahlt und wie wir
gerechtigkeit in einer krise waren
lassen zufalls gewinne die entstehen und
die energiekonzerne milliarden schwer
nach hause tragen das akzeptieren wir
nicht und die nutzen wir um sie
einzusetzen und um für entlastungen zu
sorgen in diesen zeiten und für uns ist
das auch soziale marktwirtschaft und
dafür setzen wir uns ein und deswegen
gibt es jetzt auch die strompreis bremse
und die kommt nicht nur den privaten
haushalten zugute sondern vor allen
dingen auch den kleinen und
mittelständischen unternehmen und
deswegen verteilen wir am markt das was
nicht funktioniert wir gehen aber auch
an die wurzel ran an das strom akte sein
und das muss auch kommen ich möchte noch
mal
auf einen wichtigen aspekt das
entlastungspaket eingehen und das ist
die wohngeldreform denn das ist nicht
mal eben so ein bisschen hier und da
sondern wir verdreifachen den
bezieherkreis wir sorgen dafür dass
menschen mit sehr geringen einkommen
oder rentnerinnen und rentner wohngeld
beziehen können und eine unterstützung
erhalten und wir müssen uns auch
kommunikativ in bekommen dass das keine
schande ist wenn man wohngeld bezieht
sondern dass man sagt wir als
gesellschaft wir tragen auch die die es
nicht können und deswegen ist die
wohngeldreform eines der wichtigsten
vorhaben die wir vor allem in dieser
legislatur
und ja wir schauen uns ganz genau die
wirtschaft an denn ohne arbeitsplätze
kommen wir erst recht nicht aus dieser
krise wir haben gelernt in adaptiert
dass wir uns nicht von kübel listen
leiten lassen die bedeuten jemand der im
internationalen wettbewerb steht bekommt
zuschüsse wir müssen auch die lokalen
gewerbetreibenden und die mittelständler
vor ort konkret unterstützen und
deswegen wollten wir diese liste aus
wir müssen aber auch die zukunft
gemeinsam miteinander hinguckern wir als
fraktion waren letzte woche in dresden
unser fraktionsvorsitzender rolf
mützenich hat das eben gesagt und
carsten schneider der nachher auch noch
mal hier die debatte ab wendet wird noch
einmal auf die spezifischen aspekte auch
des ostens eingehen aber was wäre da
erlebt haben ist auch der mut des
aufbruchs und die innovationen die schon
stattfindet wir haben zum beispiel ein
startup besucht mittlerweile schon
mittelstand zwölf jahre alt die stellen
elektrolyseur
anlagen zur herstellung von wasserstoff
damit wir es schaffen nicht mehr gas in
der produktion zu nutzen sondern eben
neue regenerative energien und die sind
weltmarktführer und wir müssen dafür
sorgen nicht nur mit geld das wurde in
dem gespräch sehr klar sondern vor allen
dingen mit rahmenbedingungen und
beschleunigung dass uns das jetzt
gelingt dass wir deutschland als
wirtschaft nachhaltig machen innovativ
fortschrittlich und das schneller als
wir uns vorgenommen haben und
deswegen investiert dieser haushalt auch
über 50 milliarden sind für
investitionen vorgenommen und das ist
eben auch genau dieses signal das wir
brauchen krisenbewältigung aber blick in
die zukunft und gestalten der
transformation
und ich komme zum schluss noch mal auf
you never walk alone zurück ich sprach
von der hoffnung und auch den mut den
dieses lied vermittelt wir brauchen
jetzt in der krise neben der solidarität
vor allen dingen den mut die zukunft
schneller zu gestalten als geplant dafür
sind wir in der koalition angetreten und
gemeinsam mit kanzler olaf scholz gehen
wir voran
die stellvertretende
fraktionsvorsitzende der spd fraktion ja
sie hat noch mal einen bogen geschlagen
zu der rede von olaf scholz immer noch
mal knapp vier stunden zurückgehend der
bundeskanzler hat heute morgen auch in
der generaldebatte noch mal betont man
werde zusammenhalten und you never walk
alone so sagt olaf scholz noch mal das
sei das motto dieser regierung die
aufgaben vor denen sie stehen liebe
bundesregierung lieber ampelkoalition
sind groß und werden in den nächsten
tagen und in den nächsten jahren nicht
kleiner werden wir sind nach corona
pandemie kriegerischen
auseinandersetzungen hier in europa
sozialen spannungen verstärkt durch die
inflation und instrumentalisiert durch
demokratie feinde in einem märz nun
zustand der dauerkrise gefangen die
folgen sind gravierend das fundament
unserer gesellschaft unser zusammenhalt
erodiert zusehends und in diesen
kritischen moment ist die kultur
wichtiger denn je wo sonst können
menschen ohne vorurteil zusammenkommen
ihre gemeinsamkeiten und auch ihre
unterschiede zelebrieren
vereine künstler die sich immer noch
nicht von den einschränkungen der korona
zeiten erholt haben stehen nun vor dem
nächsten großen herausforderungen
preiserhöhung neue einschränkungen für
den kommenden winter und bröckelndes
ehrenamtliches engagement
sie brauchen und verdienen jetzt unsere
unterstützung
genau jetzt müssen wir deshalb unsere
kultur und die medien stärken die stärke
einer gesellschaft misst sich an ihrem
zusammenhalt vor allem in schweren
zeiten und entsprechend auch im umgang
mit ihren minderheiten
wir die kleinen gemeinschaften sind umso
mehr von preissteigerungen und höheren
energiekosten betroffen darum ist es
wichtig dass die im vergangenen jahr
zugesagten zusätzlichen mittel für die
hier beheimateten minderheiten kein
einmaliges begrüßungsgeschenk der neuen
bundesregierung waren diese mittel
müssen verstetigt werden
andernfalls droht der verlust unserer
vielfalt und kulturelles erbe die
gemeinschaft die sprache die kultur der
hiesigen minderheiten werden sonst
verschenken liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen in einer zeit wo kräfte von
rechts und andere demokratiefeindliche
staatsführungen unsere offeneren freie
gesellschaft angreifen ist es wichtig
dagegen zu halten ein klares zeichen zu
setzen indem wir kultur und minderheiten
im im land den rücken stärken das
schafft zusammenhalt
liebe bundesregierung liebe
staatsminister roth kern sie von ihrem
weg nicht abführen sich fort was sie zum
anfang ihrer regierungszeit begonnen
haben danke
die kollegen der fanta sitzt für den
südschleswigschen wählerverband als
einziges mitglied hier im deutschen
bundestag jetzt kommen wir zur grünen
fraktion deren abgeordnete paul abbott
da spricht jetzt hier zum kanzleretat
kollegen der tod von michael bischoff
der erzeugt gerade in ostdeutschland
nicht nur dankbarkeit sondern erinnert
uns auch ganz stark an was was wir ganz
weit hinten in unserem kopf verschoben
haben nämlich dass 89 auch hätte
schiefgehen können und dann ist da nicht
nur dankbarkeit sondern da ist auch viel
erleichterung
gleichzeitig zeigt seinen weggang dass
uns immer mehr von den großen
staatsmänner und -frauen die 89 und 90
so viele richtige entscheidungen
getroffen haben verlassen und auf der
anderen seite der zeitpunkt an dem das
wiedervereinigte deutschland länger
besteht als die ddr jemals existiert hat
dieser zeitpunkt immer näher kommt und
vor dem hintergrund dieses zeitlichen
horizont ist es schon auch ein stück
weit ein eingeständnis des scheiterns
der ost west debatten der letzten drei
jahrzehnte dass wir jetzt mehr mittel
für den ostbeauftragten brauchen der für
mich aus um zusammenhalts beauftragter
ist zwischen ost und westdeutschland mit
wichtigen projekten wie hierzu weist wir
auch in zukunft um deutsche einheit
weil gerade in diesen zeiten sehen wir
ja wir haben noch keines wirklich feste
einheit in diesem land an vielen punkten
wir haben in zentralen politischen
fragen wie der unterstützung der
sanktionen zur unterstützung der ukraine
haben wir unterschiedliche politische
mehrheiten an ost- und westdeutschland
und die die jetzt spalten wollen wir
sagen ja zu recht wir lassen uns nicht
spalten in europa das bedeutet aber auch
wir lassen uns nicht spalten in den
einzelnen ländern in europa und damit in
deutschland auch nicht in ost und west
und wir lassen uns an der stelle dann
nicht spalten weder von nazis noch von
russischer propaganda noch von einzelnen
ostdeutschen ministerpräsidenten die
jetzt jede gesamtdeutsche frage zur aus
deutschen frage erklären wollen und eben
auch nicht von teilen der linkspartei
und am ende vielleicht auch
orte wie das kit und wissenschaftliche
debatten und auch debatten in der
bevölkerung angestoßen werden sollen zu
unserer sicht in ostdeutschland in
gesamtdeutschland auf osteuropa aber
auch auf unsere eigene vergangenheit das
klarmachen was eigentlich schon auf der
hand liegt nämlich dass die menschen in
der ukraine gerade für vieles kämpfen
führt dass auch die menschen 89 auf die
straße gegangen sind nämlich für
selbstbestimmung und freiheit und sie
hatten dabei deutlich mehr glück und das
finde ich verlangt auch von uns nach
viel mehr solidarität als wir das heute
zeigen kinder
[Applaus]
sepp müller hat jetzt das wort für die
cdu csu fraktion
[Applaus]
[Musik]
frau präsidentin meine sehr geehrten
damen und herren herr bundeskanzler
ihren vorherigen ausführungen in der
generaldebatte wuchtig lauschen und
zumindest wir uns ostdeutscher ist das
ein wenig an der realität vorbei sie
haben anfang ihrer legislaturperiode
gesagt sie wollen den osten stärken und
haben den staatsminister in das
kanzleramt geholt haben vor einigen
monaten eine riemser erklären auf den
weg gebracht gemeinsam mit allen
ministerpräsidenten im osten
deutschlands die inhaltlich richtig war
die deswegen auch unsere unterstützung
gefunden hat und wir diese hier zur
abstimmung im deutschen bundestag
gestellt haben dieser riemser erklärung
hat die ampelkoalition nicht gefolgt und
vor allem den worten herr bundeskanzler
die sie dort gefunden haben insbesondere
auf die besonderheiten der neuen
bundesländer einzugehen denen folgen
keine taten
anscheinend haben sie andere realitäten
im bundeskanzleramt als gesamt
deutschland und insbesondere
ostdeutschland die menschen betroffen
sind
[Applaus]
wann kommen endlich die lösungen sie
legen mit ihrer politik die angst die
axt an die wurzel der ostdeutschen
wirtschaft insbesondere des
mittelstandes
sie wissen dass mit den stickstoff
werken wittenberg piesteritz der größte
gasverbraucher in deutschland im osten
deutschland sitzt sie wissen auch und
das sagt ja auch ihre antwort auf meine
anfrage dass sie über die probleme genau
informiert sein und sie mögliche
lösungen prüfen dass mittlerweile die
ersten nachfolge unternehmen kurzarbeit
an weil das ammoniak aus bleibt
ihrer politik vom stillstand von einer
realitätsverweigerung
ist nicht markt getrieben ist nicht
technik getrieben sondern treibt die
menschen im osten deutschland in die
kurzarbeit und später in die
arbeitslosigkeit und dafür tragen sie
einzig und allein verantwortung herr
bundeskanzler
ihr entlastungspaket ist zuviel
gießkanne und zu wenig genaues die
angekündigten unternehmenshilfen gehen
absolut ins leere sie sind zu spät ich
sie sind nicht genau und sie sind vor
allem um konkret die umlage die sie
ankündigen wo die mittelständische
wirtschaft insbesondere bäckereien
darunter leiden jetzt schon in insolvenz
gehen vielleicht erklären sie ihrem
bundeswirtschaftsminister was das
bedeutet die ist sozial ungerecht
erzählen sie einer verkäuferin bei uns
in einem supermarkt mit 1500 euro netto
alleinerziehend warum sie mit ihrer
umlage zahlung unternehmen retten soll
die milliarden-gewinne dieses jahr
auszeichnen werden das ist sozial
ungerecht und hat nichts mit respekt zu
tun hat und es kann zwar sie führen
sehenden auges den mittelstand in
ostdeutschland in den ruin es drohen
nach arbeitslose insbesondere aufgrund
der besonderheit des nationalen embargos
es ist richtig dass wir uns
schnellstmöglich unabhängig machen von
russischen öl- und gaslieferungen aber
sie kennen die probleme die wir in
schwedt haben wir haben technische
probleme und da fehlen die lösung sie
wissen dass schweden mit 100% rohöl
versorgt werden muss und das
funktioniert nur wenn der rostocker
hafen ausgebaggert wird wo es dort die
antwort das funktioniert nur wenn die
pipeline mit verdichterstation aufgebaut
wird wo es doch die antwort das so
zitiert nur wenn nicht nur die züge
vorrang haben sondern wenn auch
ausreichenden materialen lokführer
vorhanden sind wo ist dort die antwort
aus dem bundeskanzleramt hier versagen
sie wenn schwedt am 11 nächsten jahres
leer läuft da wird es ihrer
verantwortung sein dass hunderte
tausende menschen in die
arbeitslosigkeit gehen und das wird
ihnen der osten nicht verzeihen der
bundeskanzler
robert habeck war ja auch in schwedt
dazu trifft folgendes zitat zu das
prinzip habe geht so
auftritte filmreif handwerkliche
umsetzung bedenklich und am ende zahlt
der bürger auf dieses zitat liebe
kollegen der sozialdemokratie stammt von
ihrem stellvertretenden
fraktionsvorsitzenden dirk wiese
anscheinend hat er robert habeck nicht
nur gestern vor im fernsehen zugeschaut
sondern auch bei seinem auftritt in
schweden wir brauchen 100 prozent
ölversorgung dann kann so vor dass
nationale embargo kommen damit die
menschen nicht nur in schweden wegen der
fernwärme am kalten sitzen sondern damit
ihr treibstoffproduktion im ganzen land
haben herr bundeskanzler
beenden sie diesen klamauk holen sie die
energie endlich ins kanzleramt halten
sie ihre versprechen für schwert für
leuna und für ganz ostdeutschland und
schaffen die sie diese unsägliche gas um
lager danke
[Applaus]
das wort hat der staatsminister carsten
schneider
beauftragte der bundesregierung für
ostdeutschland im kanzleramt kassen
schneider
co präsidentin liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen
die
förderung der lage unserer gesellschaft
hat der abgeordnete seidler gerade in
der beeindruckende art und weise
hier zu tage gebracht mich hat sie
angespannte situation beginnt mit 20 15
der situation
um die geflüchteten corona krise
insbesondere die isolation von menschen
auch wirtschaftliche schwierigkeiten
gibt spaltung der gesellschaft und jetzt
einen krieg in antriebs krieg russlands
auf ein land der
europas auf die ukraine knapp 1000
kilometer von hier entfernt
all das macht was mit unserer
gesellschaft und unserer bevölkerungen
und als bundestag und das regierung die
aufgabe übertragen dieser zeit für
ordnung zu sorgen für sicherheit aber
auch für freiheit und für kollegin pia
kommt da gerade auf hingewiesen
es hätte 89 auch anders ausgehen können
die panzer standen ja in den illegal und
die sowjetische armee hat oft genug und
das ist ja auch in der lehre die viele
ostdeutsche leiter hier 53 machen
mussten sie wollten auch eingesetzt 68
und in warschau
in den in danzig in prag und aus diesem
grund aus dieser historischen erfahrung
heraus ist der kampf um die freiheit und
die selbstbestimmung das
selbstbestimmungsrecht der völker der
entscheidende impuls in dieser liga
deutsche bundestag bei allen
ökonomischen problemen auf haben aus
und die nächsten das nächste jahr wird
schwer jeder von uns weiß dass keiner
hat eine einfache antwort darauf
wie regierung bemühen uns sowohl die
versorgungssicherheit mit energie gas
die
schwierigkeiten ist der bundeskanzlerin
wurde auch hier versäumnisse auch
eingegangen aber auch mit rohöl kollege
müller und wer arbeitet mit hochdruck an
einer lösung für die raffinerien später
war auch für den standort in leuna und
kann ihn so viel sagen möchte sie gerne
auch unter vier augen dazu dass das auf
gutem weg ist so dass wir unabhängig
werden auch von russischen öl denn wer
sagt uns denn das latino putin damit
wartet auf den ersten erst 2023 um auch
die höhe das öl durch die durchleitung
abzustellen um uns zu erpressen wir
wollen darauf nicht warten wir wollen
eigene wege gehen wer die
versorgungssicherheit in deutschland ist
von dort aus deutschland sicherstellen
diesen bundestage diese regierung kommt
eine große verantwortung zu auch den
zusammenhalt in unserem land zu
gewährleisten
und er wird für große herausforderung
gestellt viele menschen werden angst
haben und mir ihre wohnung einkommen
unternehmen viele handwerkerin hat
berger die vor 30 jahren die unternehmen
gegründet haben und jetzt angst haben
noch berechtigte sorge das geht bei den
preisen kommt darauf hingewiesen weil es
was wir tun können dies zu dämpfen die
möglichkeiten zu geben sowohl sozial die
situation über wohngeld
ausweitung aber auch transfers auch
direkte transfers von arbeitgeber und
arbeitnehmer die 3000 euro werden wir
das als regierung tun aber wir werden
nicht um stillstand verharren sondern
auch nach vorn investieren und da ist
ostdeutschland ist dass dieser haushalt
eines der zentralen punkte die region
hält dort wird wir geben ostdeutschland
eine ganz besondere priorität und dieses
land hat von ostdeutschland unheimlich
viel insbesondere bayern-kollege
dobrindt denke an die vielen
denker die vier in den osten nach bayern
gegangen sind dort zu arbeiten sich dort
auch wohl fühlen ich denke aber auch an
die energieversorgung ich meine dass
ihre ministerpräsident nach mecklenburg
vorpommern kommen musste um bei manuela
schwesig auch mal danke zu sagen dass
dort entschied terminals gebaut werden
dass wir die gasversorgung bei uns mit
sicherstellen können ist glaube ich ein
punkt wo ich glaube das ist wichtig und
gut zu wissen wir sind ein land wir sind
ein land die macht ist etwas begonnen da
wird so besser auf die boden der
tatsachen auch wieder geholt aber wir
garantieren auch die wirtschaftlichen
investitionen und das sind viele große
namen letzten jahren die sie hier
entschieden haben in ostdeutschland zu
siedeln in einem tesla wir haben in
thüringen das batteriewerk c rtl wir
haben die grundsätzliche entscheidung
von intel in
magdeburg zu investieren dies alles
folgt auch der entscheidung dieser
bundesregierung das auch finanziell zu
unterstützen und auch zu sagen das soll
nach aus deutschland kommen und es folgt
aber auch eine politische entscheidung
von landesregierung zum beispiel
erneuerbare energien auszubauen und das
zum beispiel das land brandenburg 95
prozent seines gesamten bedarf
mittlerweile aus erneuerbaren energien
deckt zeigt dass dieser weg der weg der
freiheit des fortschritts aber auch der
zukünftigen arbeitsplätze ist bei sonst
hätte sich tesla niemals dort
angesiedelt wir unterstützen das wo
immer wir können und manchmal lohnt auch
der blick von außen auf unser land und
zitiert die financial times das ist
dieses vorhaben der blattgröße
wirtschaftsblatt europas das hat im juni
war es glaube ich einen großen artikel
geschrieben
über aus deutschland wird der titel ist
die überraschende neubelebung ost satz
ein neuer blick und so möchte ich auch
dass wir einen neuen blick darauf werden
wir sind nicht diejenigen die gestützt
werden müssen wir werden diejenigen sein
die dieses land mit steht sowohl was die
energie betrifft aber auch was
arbeitsplätze und vor allen dingen was
zukunft betrifft und wir waren herr
bundeskanzler durch den begleiten
gemeinsam mit den drei
ministerpräsidenten der kohle länder am
folgewoche in schwarze pumpe
diese drei länder haben ein großes
strukturwandel vorsicht diese steigen
aus der kohle aus den kuckuck den
kollegen kollegen die den kraftwerken so
arbeiten die die braunkohle kraftwerke
wieder hochfahren ins kontor weil er
dankbar dass sie diesen job machen weil
nur das sichert unsere energieversorgung
aber wir steigen langfristig daraus aus
und diese bundesregierung dieser
bundestag hat beschlossen finanziell das
zu begleiten diese 40 milliarden euro
auch für nrw stehen zur verfügung und
werden zum beispiel auch in zwei
großforschungseinrichtungen jetzt
investiert das für mich ist er wird dazu
in der nächsten zeit
forschungsministerium entscheidend alles
in allem glaube wir sind auf einem guten
weg sind schwierige harte zeit wir
müssen sehen dass wir das land
zusammenhalten dass wir die unterschiede
erkennen auch verstehen aber beieinander
bleiben vielen dank
und es wird sicher mit blick auf den
herbst
wenn die energiepreise je nachdem wie
sich die energiepreise entwickeln wie
gut entlastungsmaßnahmen wirken
dann
ein bestimmendes thema johannes huber
jetzt fraktionslos
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
mitbürger der bundeshaushalt ist nach
allen regeln der kunst geschönt die
echte nettokreditaufnahme war trotz des
todes hohen steuereinnahmen bereits vor
dem dritten sogenannten entlastungspaket
viermal höher als angegeben man muss
wahrlich keine schwäbische hausfrau sein
um zu erkennen dass angesichts der
kommenden der rezession bis hin zur
depression
die gasanlage und die gewinnsteuer für
energieunternehmen nur der anfang sind
und weitere massive steuererhöhungen und
abgaben vor allem von den arbeiten ein
teil der bevölkerung folgen werden es
ist damit leider nur eine frage der zeit
bis es auch in deutschland zu den von
ihnen befürchteten und auch selbst
verursachten volksaufständen kommen wird
christian lindner hatte vor meseberg
nach angemahnt dass man auch an die
probleme an die wurzel der probleme
gehen muss weil nach meseberg davon aber
nichts zu sehen ist muss es die aufgabe
des deutschen bundestags sein endlich
fest stellen dass der verursacher der
energiekrise die ideologische
energiewende ist eine energiewende die
eine ganze nation abhängig macht von
wind und sonne zeigt bereits die ganze
idiotie und kann physikalisch nicht
funktionieren um die dunkle flaute zu
überstehen und ein minimum an
grundlastfähiger energie zu haben haben
sich die regierungen von gas abhängig
gemacht von dem aktuell auch noch mehr
verstromt wird also lange zeit zuvor es
haben also nicht nur die letzten beiden
bundeskanzler schröder und merkel
sondern jeder der in den letzten
jahrzehnten die energiewende unterstützt
hat deutschland wissentlich an putin
ausgeliefert mit dem weiterbetrieb von
einzelnen kohlekraftwerken hat sich die
bundesregierung bereits insgeheim
eingestanden dass die energiewende
bereits gescheitert ist anstatt aber die
zeitenwende mit einer notwendigen 180
grad wende in der energiepolitik
umzusetzen und den unternehmen wie den
bürgern bezahlbare energie warme
wohnungen und sogar warmes wasser zu
liefern boykottiert die regierung lieber
freiwillig ölimporte und verlangt
historisch hohe steuern auf sprints so
dass der liter bald drei euro kostet
unendlich der grüne traum in erfüllung
geht dass sich keiner mehr auto oder lkw
fan leisten kann zu allem überfluss
wollen das umweltbundesamt und der
landwirtschaftsminister özdemir auch
noch das behelfsmäßige heizen mit holz
verbieten mit der strompreis bremse
gesteht sich die regierung übrigens die
nächste realität ein dass wir nicht nur
eine gaskrise sondern auch eine strom
krise haben obwohl sie das immer
verneint hat für die dauer der
kohleverstromung müssen also die
belastenden co2 zertifikate ausgesetzt
werden um rationierungen und
flächendeckende stromausfälle
über den winter hinaus zu vermeiden
hätten jetzt mehrjährige
laufzeitverlängerungen der
kernkraftwerke folgen müssen aber robert
habeck hat entschieden dass sich die
deutschen privat auf einem blackout
vorbereiten dürfen zuletzt gibt es kein
argument das nicht heuchlerisch ist
warum man sich mit dem umweltschädlichen
transport von flüssiggas und wasserstoff
erneut abhängig macht aber in
deutschland verbietet im nationalen
interesse die eigenen der reichhaltigen
gasressourcen zu fördern
es ist schon zuletzt eine makabre ironie
des schicksals dass das einzige das die
bundesregierung jetzt retten kann der
von ihr bekämpfte klimawandel also ein
milder winter ist viel spaß damit
vier fraktionslose abgeordnete sitzen
derzeit im deutschen bundestag johannes
huber hier der gesprochen hat ist eine
von ihnen er ist im dezember 2021 aus
der fdp bundestagsfraktion
ausgeschieden jetzt für die grünen
julian parke ihr als nächster redner
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin sehr
geehrte demokraten es ist jetzt etwas
mehr als ein jahr her dass die
bundeswehr aus afghanistan abgezogen
wurde dieses scheitern unserer
staatlichen strukturen ist so groß dass
dieser bundestag für die untersuchung
des einsatzes gleich zwei gremien
beschlossen hat über die parteigrenzen
hinweg viel ist können wir aufarbeiten
aber das wird niemals etwas an der
tatsache ändern dass viele viele
menschen von uns zurückgelassen wurden
nicht nur unsere lokalen mitarbeiter in
auch die menschen die sich für ein
freies und demokratisches afghanistan
eingesetzt haben in der presse oder als
aktivistin mit unendlichem mut und der
hoffnung auf ein freies land und ein
leben in frieden und während die uhren
heute in afghanistan rückwärtsgehen
gefährdete menschen auf ganz hausherren
unterdrückt werden oder sich auf eine
lebensgefährliche und ungewisse flucht
begeben diskutieren wir seit monaten
darüber wie das bundes auf name programm
das wir uns im koalitionsvertrag
geeinigt haben umgesetzt werden soll
diese zeit haben wir nicht denn diese
zeit haben vor allem die menschen vor
ort nicht ich war selbst im juni im
nachbarland pakistan und habe mich mit
afghanen getroffen die es über die
grenze geschafft haben ich habe sie in
einem safe house besucht wo sie sich
gerade verstecken aus angst dass sie
entdeckt uns nach afghanistan
verschleppt werden ich konnte ihnen
nicht erklären warum sie nicht
ausgeflogen werden und sie und ihre
angehörigen
sich weiter von der taliban fürchten und
verstecken müssen
während des afghanistan einsatzes
während der afghanistan einsatz lief
haben manche gesagt dass die sicherheit
europas auch am hindukusch verteidigt
wird der einsatz ist jetzt beendet das
einzige was wir heute noch am hindukusch
verteidigen können ist die sicherheit
der gefährdeten afghane diese schuld für
das versagen beim bundeswehrabzug trägt
die vorherige bundesregierung aber diese
bundesregierung trägt die verantwortung
dafür dass wir diese menschen nicht
zurücklassen denn das ist eine frage von
würde
es ist eine frage von würde dass das
aufnahmeprogramm jetzt endlich
beschlossen wird und ihr gefährt und den
menschen eine perspektive und vor allem
sicherheit geben dabei haben wir dieses
jahr doch gezeigt wie schnell und
entschlossen wir reagieren kann wenn
menschen aus einem kriegsgebiet schutz
brauchen wir haben es geschafft menschen
aus der ukraine schnell und
unbürokratisch aufzunehmen wenn wir sind
doch angetreten weil wir dinge anders
machen wollten progressiver
pragmatischer und einiges ist schon
passiert aber wir haben noch vieles auf
dem zettel wir treten ein für ein
humanitäres aufnahmeprogramm ein starkes
resettlement programm und gleichstellung
im familiennachzug wir haben den
paradigmenwechsel in der migrations und
integrationspolitik angekündigt mit dem
chancen aufenthaltsrecht haben wir jetzt
ein anfang gemacht und wir arbeiten im
herbst an den nächsten gesetzespaket im
koalitionsvertrag haben wir auch die
klare versprechungen gemacht das leben
von geflüchteten menschen zu verbessern
menschen mit einem unsicheren
aufenthalts und in prekären umständen
die integrationskurse sollen allen
menschen offen stehen die nach
deutschland kommen ob aus der ukraine
oder aus afghanistan all das all diese
gemeinsamen pläne müssen sich auch so im
haushalt abbilden denn fortschritt
fortschritt bedeutet auch die
wahrnehmung humanitäre verantwortung
nur so schaffen wir perspektiven für
menschen die wir das mittelmeer fliehen
oder die in diesem moment in einem safe
aus in islamabad oder in einem keller in
kabul sitzen vielen dank
jetzt haben wir als nächsten einen
weiteren fraktionslosen abgeordneten der
hier im bundestag sitzt matthias
helferich wird es sein die
fraktionslosen immer mit etwas
eingeschränkten redezeiten drei minuten
damen und herren stolz lobte
grünen-parteichef nouripour nach der
verkündung des jüngsten entlastungs
paketes den winter der solidarität aus
der fdp vize johannes vogel erklärte
putin führt einen wirtschaftskrieg gegen
uns alle und den darf er nicht gewinnen
da kommen wir alle nicht zumutung frei
durch doch wo sind sie solidarisch
welche zumutung muss die herrschende
klasse in kauf nehmen für die
erweiterung des bundeskanzleramt das
pressen sie unser volk
639 millionen euro solidarität
fehlanzeige
die gleichstellung der ukrainischen
flüchtlinge mit deutschen hartz 4
empfängern kostet unser volk 150
millionen euro im monat solidarität
fehlanzeige über acht milliarden euro ab
ohne die jährlich an gez gebühren für
ihre teils kriminelle entrückte hof
journaille solidarität fehlanzeige unser
volk wird in dieser hausgemachten krise
mit almosen abgespeist almosen unser
volk selbst erwirtschaftet hat und die
sie ihm nun im rahmen eines gnadenakt es
überreichen unser volk darf sich über
einmalzahlungen und soll sich ansonsten
in die immer länger werdenden schlangen
der tafeln einreihen solidarisch wäre es
wenn die grünen ihre moralische
überheblichkeit überwinden und wir
endlich zur kernenergie zurückkehren
würden solidarisch wäre es wenn sie ihre
migration zucht mal auf entzug stehen
würden und 300.000 illegale außer landes
bringen würden solidarisch wäre es eine
verschwenderische entwicklungspolitik zu
beenden es kann doch nicht sein dass
afrika kassiert und deutschlands wir es
gibt keine solidarität von rechts sagt
die politische linke doch das gegenteil
ist richtig wie der publizist benedikt
kaiser zurecht anmerkte konkrete
solidarität ist rechts und abstrakte
solidarität
links sie fühlen sich dem weltklima der
weltgemeinschaft der weltrettung
verpflichtet aber wir stehen an der
seite unserer leute sie sind nicht
solidarisch im einzelplan 04 des
bundeskanzleramtes verzichten sie nicht
auf die millionenschwere pfändung der
migrations lobby den kampf gegen rechts
oder die üppige förderung des
zentralrats der roma sie schaffen die
co2 abgabe nicht endlich ab sie setzten
nur die erhöhung aus sie sind wir ein
deal der dem opfer etwas übrig lässt und
dann im nächsten jahr an neu zuzugreifen
diese politischen opportunitäten kitzeln
inzwischen in weisen energiesparer
schlägen ich sag nur waschlappen statuts
es wieder einen urlaub nehmen sie selbst
liebe bundesregierung die waschlappen
die sie unserem volk empfehlen und gehen
sie mit gutem beispiel voran vielen dank
[Applaus]
so matthias hilfrich war das jetzt hören
wir hier in dieser generaldebatte
mit nach vorne bringen noch diese dann
auf der regierungsbank oder anderswo
verteilen also insofern können wir das
dem
eigentümer sicherlich nachher wieder
zurückgeben
das wort ja die ermahnung von
bundestagsvizepräsidentin petra pau was
hier mit dem waschlappen passiert ist
von matthias hilfe riecht das ist hier
nicht parlamentarisch
gestattet matthias hauer jetzt letzter
redner in dieser generalaussprache
europa und unser land in eine schwere
krise viele menschen können die hohen
preise nicht mehr bezahlen viele
mittelständler droht der ruin und in
solchen schweren zeiten hat deutschland
einen bundeskanzler dessen
glaubwürdigkeit ein tiefpunkt erreicht
hat und das hängt auch mit seiner rolle
im comex steuerskandal zusammen um es
klar zu sagen ich holz hat den bundestag
belogen
das ist ein zitat der sehr geschätzten
kollegin lisa paus von den grünen gerade
einmal zwei jahre ist es her dass die
heutige bundesministerin olaf scholz
mehrfach und ausdrücklich der lüge
bezichtigt hat 70 prozent der menschen
in deutschland nehmen olaf scholz sei
der erinnerungslücken in der comex
steueraffäre nicht ab sogar eine
mehrheit 56 prozent der spd-anhänger
glauben glauben ihnen nicht nur elf
prozent tun das besagt eine
repräsentative umfrage die menschen in
deutschland spüren so etwas sehr genau
der bundeskanzler sagt nicht das was er
weiß und lassen sie mich kurz die
erinnerung auffrischend worum geht es
bei comics kriminelle banker und
investoren haben aktiengeschäfte allein
aus einem ziel getätigt sich einmal
abgeführte kapitalertragsteuer doppelt
erstatten zu lassen der start wurde so
zur beute gemacht allein im fall der
hamburger privatbank warburg sollten die
steuerzahler um einen dreistelligen
millionenbetrag
drogen werden dass diese wundersame form
der geldvermehrung höchst kriminell ist
das drängt sich nicht nur heben auf
sondern das hat auch der bundesfinanzhof
klar bestätigt ganz deutschland kämpfte
dafür dass kriminelle geraubte
steuermilliarden zurückzahlen müssen
ganz deutschland nein
einzig die freie und hansestadt hamburg
war unbeugsam unter dem damaligen erster
oben erster bürgermeister olaf scholz
war hamburg das paradies für die
verantwortlichen dieses steuer raubs und
von jedem regierungschef muss erwartet
werden dass er dafür kämpft geraubtes
steuergeld von kriminellen zurückzuholen
doch olaf stolz olaf scholz tat das
gegenteil
er rief er rief sie an er traf sich
sogar persönlich mit ihnen nicht einmal
nicht zweimal
mindestens drei mal trat er sich mit den
warburg kriminellen in seiner amtsstube
obwohl er wusste dass comex höchst
kriminell ist und dass gegen seine
gesprächspartner zum damaligen zeitpunkt
wegen schwerer steuerhinterziehung
ermittelt wurde und der bundeskanzler
behauptet er erinnere sich an nichts das
ist völlig unglaubwürdig natürlich
erinnert man sich an eine angelegenheit
dieser tragweite bei dem man sich
mehrfach mit kriminellen getroffen hat
die auch noch behauptet haben die
existenz einer wichtigen hamburger bank
mit 1000 arbeitsplätzen sei in gefahr
gewesen für die auch viel hamburger spd
prominenz um herrn stolz herum probiert
hatte wenige tage nach dem gespräch mit
herrn scholz legte die stadt hamburg
dann ganz plötzlich eine 180 grad
wendung hin wollte plötzlich auf die
steuermillionen zugunsten der bank
verzichten am ende musste das
bundesfinanzministerium mit weisungen
die notbremse ziehen an nichts davon
wollen sie sich ja immer mehr stolz
obwohl sie mitten drin war herr
bundeskanzler ich glaube ihnen kein wort
und auch in ihrer heutigen rede zeigen
die erinnerungslücken wer war denn in
der letzten regierung vizekanzler mit
einer ausnahme von vier jahren hat die
spd seien 98 durchgehend regiert jetzt
sei alles schulter opposition und den
ampeln oder alle probleme schon lösen
bevor andere die probleme überhaupt nur
erkennen woher nehmen sie eigentlich
diese maßlose selbstüberschätzung
sie reißen wieso hat die brückenbauer
die gesamtdauer
die gesamte opposition wollte olaf
scholz vor ist ein im finanzausschuss zu
comics befragen der bundeskanzler ist
nicht erschienen die ampel hat die
befragung mit der mehrheit verhindert
aber es kommen neue erkenntnisse ans
licht durch ermittlungen von
staatsanwaltschaft durch investigative
journalistinnen und journalisten durch
den hamburger untersuchungsausschuss
private jets in den hamburger
finanzbeamte über einen teuflischen plan
sprechen 100.000 euro bargeld im
bankschließfach des ehemaligen chef
haushälter des kollegen
ich habe die uhr angehalten
gestatten sie eine frage oder
bemerkungen des kollegen limburg aus der
fraktion bündnis 90
hätte ich mich gar nicht so bereiten
müssen
das war der die wahre intention meiner
frage vielen dank herr kollege dass sie
die zwischenbemerkungen zu lassen ich
begrüße es ausdrücklich dass sie das
wichtige thema comics hier nochmal so
prominenter stelle aufrufen weil es
natürlich dass gerechtigkeit
gerechtigkeitsgefühl der menschen in
diesem land zutiefst verletzt und
beleidigt aber das betrifft nicht die
vorgänge in hamburg allein sondern das
betrifft den comic skandal in seiner
gänze und ich darf ihr gedächtnis
dahingehend auffrischen das ist nicht
richtig ist was sie behauptet haben dass
hier sämtliche politikern politiker
aller couleur außer olaf scholz sich
bemüht hätten comics zu unterbinden und
die gelder zurückzuholen ist weil ihr
bundesfinanzminister wolfgang schäuble
und ich beziehe mich hier nur auf die
eigenen aussagen des früheren
bundesfinanzministers dem
bundestagspräsidenten der
bundesfinanzminister der seit anfang
2010 persönlich kenntnis von den comics
konstrukten hatte anfang 2010 und was
hat er gemacht anfang 2007 mitte 2010
ende 2007 er hat nichts gemacht um die
comics geschäfte zu unterbinden er ist
so 2012 ist die gesetzesänderung in
kraft getreten und anschließend hat
wolfgang schäuble und die union wieder
jahre lang nichts gemacht dass herr auer
ist die wahrheit also wenn sie comics
aufarbeiten wollen wenn sie comics zu
recht anprangern dann beleuchten sie
doch bitte auch ihre eigene rolle und
die rolle der union in diesem skandal
[Applaus]
herr kollege vielen dank dass sie mir
die gelegenheit geben da noch etwas
ausführlicher so auszuführen ist es
erstmal schön dass wir uns einig sind
dass es sich um ein steuer raub geht der
auch aufgearbeitet werden muss und ich
nehme dieser sie da beim wort wenn es da
um konkrete details geht auch um die
warburg bank auch in hamburg dann nehme
ich hier sie beim wort auch ihre
fraktion dass sie an der aufarbeitung
mitwirken und nicht
stücke ins getriebe werfen so das ist
das ein ansonsten möchte ich darauf
hinweisen dass es am anfang als bekannt
wurde es gibt dieses thema es gibt
dieses problem da war natürlich ein ganz
anderer kenntnisstand als es heute
gegeben war und sie verschweigen dabei
ja wir reden jetzt über einen zeitpunkt
der liegt jahre vor dem themen die ich
gerade zu herrn scholz gesagt habe so
sie verschweigen dass das finanzminister
schäuble diesem system jahr ein riegel
vorgeschoben hat und sie verschweigen
dass es peter altmaier als
bundesfinanzminister war der überhaupt
dafür gesorgt hat dass hamburg nicht
damit durchgekommen ist dass diese
millionen den steuergeldern erlassen
wurden sondern der dafür gesorgt hat
durch weisungen dass herr scholz das
geld eintreiben musste das hätte zur
weiter zugehört hätte ihnen gut zu
gesicht gestanden wenn sie das auch
erwähnt hätten und jetzt kommen neue
erkenntnisse ans licht der welt whatsapp
chats ich erwähnte das bargeld im
bankschließfach von herrn k 's ich hätte
ihn gerne gehört heute in dieser
generaldebatte hätten wir mit ihm
sicherlich einiges zu besprechen gab
vielleicht auch herr scholz denn er hat
ja auch schon fleißig für herrn warburg
wäre die warburg-bank werbung gemacht in
hamburg es gibt staatsanwaltschaftliche
durchsuchungen es gibt unstimmigkeiten
in den e mail postfächern von herrn
scholz und seiner lage büroleiterin es
gibt gezielte lösungen von scholz daten
herr bundeskanzler
sie sind beim comic skandal teil des
problems nicht teil der lösung machen
sie endlich reinen tisch zu ihrer rolle
in diesem steuer auch hier vor dem
parlament und vor allem auch von der
deutschen öffentlichkeit und denken sie
bitte auch an die worte
familienministerin vielen dank für die
aufmerksamkeit